[Music]
[Music]
and that is the Hyatt Regency of
Yekaterinburg where seven rounds of
chess were played in the first half of
the 2020 candidates to determine that
challenger to Magnus Carlsen for the
world champion match but yeah sir I'm
still in shock I can't believe it I
hadn't dropped my head around it but the
candidates is postponed
there will be no round today and there
will be no around for the foreseeable
future until things calm down exactly
well indeed everybody thank you for
joining us here today in chess it was a
shocking development as earlier this
morning the fidei announced that the
2020 candidates tournament has been
stopped and it will be postponed until
the time to be determined in the near
future the first half of the tournament
was completed was played and when the
tournament does continue again the first
half results will count so let's just
see what's in the history books and the
official announcement first from feeding
starting March 27 that's tomorrow
Russia interrupts air traffic with other
countries without indicating any time
frames in this situation FINA president
decided to stop the tournament
essentially they were worried that the
feed that the players would be stranded
in Russia which is no way of getting
home which is currently what they're
dealing with the players are scrambling
to get out of Russia as we speak right
now some of them are already in Moscow
taking a commercial flight some of them
will be in a charter flight directly to
Europe there's still a lot of details
that are unknown some of the seconds are
having problems but a very fluid
situation right few things that we know
there will be no tournament starting
today they will be played at some other
time we don't know if it'll be in your
cutting board but we're hoping the
standings will stay so these players
will be the ones that continue and this
are the players that will continue with
the
exact scores yanukovych a maxima Sheila
graph with four and our points a lead
not commanding still plenty of
tournament to be played and the other
half of the event exactly we can take a
look at the schedule first round-robin
seven rounds played second round robin
to be determined we don't know when it
will be played we have more official
announcements to do that the feed a
president has said that he hopes that
Russia will again host the second half
and specifically Yekaterinburg it's as
well exactly and he hoped also that the
Challenger would be determined in time
for the Dubai World Championship match
which does not mean scheduled for
December correct well Marissa chimed in
here well what are your thoughts about
this what a big development indeed a big
development certainly a lot of
controversy around this event even
beginning and now that it is concluded
in such a remarkable fashion the world
is swirling with this kind of news
certainly we sympathize with the players
we sympathize with their seconds we
sympathize with the officials from all
around the world who had to come to this
event including our own Leonard
Otis who is on the side who was on the
side we hope that he gets back home to
his family safely as well we've had
tweets from all around the world we
continue to bring them to you one on an
Instagram account from somebody who had
a lot to say before this sort of meant
tomorrow raja baath who said no words
can describe my feelings right now
certainly a lot of people in hindsight
saying he was justified in not wanting
to be a part of this event and not
wanting to see the event continue itself
the like I said the Twitterverse is
exploding right now with responses
relative to that as well
and we also have one of the players
Fabiano Caruana who has made his
feelings publicly felt the candidates is
over for now the hard part still remains
getting home
I expect to reenter world are hardly
recognizing difficult times indeed we
will continue to give you updates as the
show on false well thank you for that
Maurice and indeed there's a lot more
official announcements we will try to
get to us take a look this is by the
feat a president Arkady dvorkovich the
second half and I believe this was
pretty rushed out of the press the
second half will take place when the
situation will normalize we are hoping
it can be held in the same location we
have an agreement with our main partners
similan and we try to make this happen
we should be in time to determine the
runner-up I believe he means Challenger
and prepare in time for the World
Championship match that will start in
December in Dubai so we should have a
challenger determined by that point
plenty of time for them to prepare we'll
see about that and the second half is
that the decision was based on a
combination of factors however the main
one being that a few hours ago it was
announced that for the time being
flights from Russia abroad including
charter flights are stopped that is just
not incoming flights it's also outgoing
flights we could take not take the risk
to keep the players for a long time in
Russia after the tournament ends since
we don't know how long it will last
combined with the risks we are dealing
with all throughout the tournament which
we were able to minimize there was
enough reason to postpone so players as
I said are scrambling to get home
Billy vanish Garry is currently in
Moscow in the airport on his way there
Fabiana Karan is scheduled to be on a
charter flight to Amsterdam where he
will be able to grab a flight to Detroit
and get home here in st. Louis and how
is currently on his way to Tokyo so a
lot of questions still to be answered
sure but we will have the
director-general feeding a meal suit off
ski here on the show with us in about 10
minutes so stick around we'll be asking
him all kinds of questions I'll be
keeping an eye on the chat as well to
see if there's anything interesting that
pops up plenty
of stuff to talk about yes sir exact or
me of a young player is unprecedented
I've never seen this happen right I
recall back in 1984 1985 the stoppage of
the world championship match that was 48
games and as you all remember it was the
first player to win six games and the
match was stopped aborted as they say at
five to three and Gary had actually made
and remarkable comeback from being down
five zero but from the candidates you'd
almost have to go back to the outbreak
of World War two in 1939 when the
Olympiad was being held in Buenos Aires
and a lot of teams got stuck in
Argentina and they couldn't return to
Europe as you as war had broken out in
Europe so this is really well I mean in
our lifetimes definitely extraordinary
and you know something from the from
from the get-go this tournament felt a
little bit ill-fated I mean obviously
the pandemic to begin with and the fact
that so many international bodies
sporting bodies around the world at
canceled events and that feed a decided
contrary to them all that they were
going to press the head that was a
really extraordinary it was like they
were the last gladiators in the world
sporting world still their Krista said
it himself we are the largest the only
major sport that's still going on
exactly and it just have to be stopped
at and it wasn't because any of the
players got sick they had thought about
this there were rules in place of what
happened to one of the players got
coronavirus but it ought to do they got
sick without coronavirus right and none
of that happened it was actually even
another thing Russia decided to close
its borders right and that precipitated
the decision of the fee day yeah
Maurice I'm betting here with your your
thoughts too about this breaking news
well absolutely it's a stunning thing to
happen everyone has concerns for their
family and friends the players
themselves expressed that they were
thinking about home a lot of times it
was very difficult to focus on chess
100% because home and and the events of
the world were always on their minds
they still had to play some were
affected differently from others
depending on who you talk to I know
I got a message I saw something about
from mvl who said that you know he was
basically able to tune things out
because he was playing chess and he was
in that zone but I don't think it was
that easy for other players who see him
here he was leading the tournament at
least mathematically tiebreaks because
he did defeat his co-leader
a young the pom the Chi in their
head-to-head confrontation just
yesterday he certainly was on a rise he
got here in a remarkable way because a
player decided not to play that player
being timur raja baath and just being
here he was taking his chance I can
imagine how he's feeling right now as
well stopping right in the middle maybe
felt he was on a roll to have to restart
completely we see there he drew his
first round and he won against England
it was multiple drawers before he took
on the leader of the event in round
seven and when he needed to he won and
he's now standing in a remarkable place
by the way it's conceivable that the
tournament may be canceled what if they
cannot continue this event later in the
year will they just declare him the
finalist that would cause its own
storyline as well so absolutely
remarkable situation well talk about
controversy I think that's mine raja
baath will he be included in any way in
the following part of the tournament the
answer is it's pretty clear know there
will be a no 9th player attitude
tournament the tournament settings will
not change this will be the tournament
that we happen this will be the
tournament moving on precisely
now of course hindsight is 20/20 but you
can't help but ask is there a job of a
real victim here he was very adamant
that the servant should not happen right
because of everything that's going on in
the world and the tournament it was
stopped yes
and the job of yeah you can basically
say he was right yes I mean
unfortunately yes but once the
tournament did get started I mean once
the very first round played and
you know results occurred you could say
that the candidates 2020 was underway
and Timur was out of the competition yes
absolutely there's no way back for him
into it and yeah well that's his bottom
exactly so his first spot in it that
will be in going on where he's go ahead
I also saw no interview from the voir
kovitch himself
they had a feed a who said that his
problem with the approach that raja
baath had was that he demanded one of
two things it was a yes or no situation
it wasn't let's talk about it let's
discuss its you should stop this event
or so I'm not playing
and that dictatorial standpoint was what
he was not happy about now again we look
at it in hindsight it's very easy it's
clear that there's concerns that
everybody had around this event and the
fact that it was going it was proceeding
a pace they were doing all their medical
tests and the like still didn't elate
all the concerns of me everybody said
wait a minute
you know we see you're trying to make
sure the players are healthy and the
like but nevertheless anything could
happen it looks like anything did in
this case something that they could not
have foreseen was Russia actually
shutting down air travel now I'm curious
to know what's going on in Russia itself
this is a dramatic decision on the part
of Russia what is what were the thoughts
going into the federal government's
decision to say let's stop air travel
that it that's gonna be its own breaking
news not chest news per se but
international news itself and it means a
lot for people who are trapped in that
country or maybe trapped because they
can't get out today well we've got a lot
of a lot of under and answer questions a
very very fluid situation still it
happened very quickly at midnight they
will close down everything Bobby's
actually getting on the 11 p.m. flight
today yeah yeah it's already 6 p.m. or
in Russia and you
specifically right so they do need to
get on that flight it is the last vibe
that will leave for Europe in the
foreseeable future we want to open up
our show to any callers I just want to
say that if you do have a question make
it quickly brief or comment quickly and
briefly as in five minutes Emile su toss
will be joining us will definitely take
some of the best questions something we
can probably ask Emil exactly because we
will definitely have our own series of
questions for him our phone number is
three one four three six one five four
six five and whoa and you got it you got
to think I mean you just said something
that that for me personally would be of
dramatic concern to to family and
friends because somebody says you're
getting on the 11 p.m. flight okay you
know as a flyer we all have been on
flights that got delayed yes right right
the tie it happens all the time yeah
weather weather for example something
happens and if the weather you know
anything could happen so this is why
it's such a concerning situation because
the players now have heard by Fiat from
somewhere else completely out of their
control I mean within the feed a circle
and and Yekaterinburg they pretty much
were well informed about everything but
to suddenly hear that complete external
circumstances somebody says you cannot
get on a flight post 12 o'clock I can't
imagine what the players are thinking
well it would be freaking you know yeah
freaking out is put it mildly everybody
is scrambling right they're pretty much
trying to get out of Russia however they
can right the situation is very
difficult but well there's eight of them
as far as I'm concerned and I've heard
all of them are either on their way or
have a plan to get out of there yeah the
three Russians of course of course find
but it's the other five players and the
Chinese players especially - I mean it's
a awkward situation for them because
China itself is worried about you know
getting a rebound a rebound from
incoming traffic travelers yes and we do
have a phone call from Austin I believe
please give us your name and a brief
question hey yeah this is Patrick from
Austin Texas great job kind of
surprising I saw Daniel normally how
they can pronounce his name correctly
yes Roger but officers automatically get
a feed and 2022 candidates what do you
guys think about that well we do have a
wild card for a reason and there's
nothing that says that in the 2022
edition you can't make a rule for that I
would be surprised if he did that that
field leadership doesn't tend to cater
to well to players that decide to cancel
events about right yeah it wasn't a
consensus that the player said oh we
don't want to do this it wasn't a job of
in some kind of negotiations right that
was pretty much dropped out exactly and
now feet is perfectly capable of saying
well you dropped out you're not our
business anymore on a personal note yeah
I think that that would be a reasonable
decision of fee day or somebody's
decision to say you know what all that
feelings aside let's just I mean yes fee
data's may not normally cater to that
but I suppose previous feed a leadership
as well you've got a brand new
leadership on board his leadership
Arkady dvorkovich whose birthday happens
to be today
happy birthday what's what a thing to
have to do I mean this will be a
memorable birthday for him for sure what
a thing to have to decide on your
birthday it means I'm you want it you
want to celebrate you're gonna get your
cake and beat your family get your well
wishes from all around the world and all
you might be getting is hate mail right
I mean it's a horrible situation to have
to experience if you're in his shoes and
I can imagine somebody saying you know
what maybe previous video demonstrations
might have said something but I'm gonna
take a stance and say you know let's
just water under the bridge let's forget
about it and bring your job off into the
tournament in 2022 which I think many of
the fans would think is a reasonable
compromise yeah but do remember that
people that are hoping for that
wild-card spot themselves might see it
US unfair because there will be
wild-card spot some people want this is
one of the most coveted spots in the
entire world of chess we do have another
question from Tennessee so again please
your name and a real question yes my
name is Bronn I want to know without is
going
should CD or fader start might be
scheduling advances magnitude like the
candidates in the World Championship in
non-code whether month oh there you go
question about whether the virus was
temperature related summer we don't know
that yet we don't know enough data they
will have to post it at some point right
and it has to be before December and you
have to give the certain amount of time
for the players to prepare and so I
would be shocked if they can host it I
think September's really the latest you
can host this right but he also said
should he has a bigger question he's
Russian was should events of any type be
how important events of this type should
be held in non non cold weather months
in warmer months well we will ask that
question directly to Emil sitarski who
is with us now on the line welcome Emil
Feder director give us your exact title
Emil and also tell us the thinking that
went on in making this happen
I think guys you are professional enough
to do ready for titling me not okay yeah
I'm talking not as a grandmaster but as
director general of feed there right
exactly the thinking that went on into
making this happen
give us today's I imagine you guys had a
meeting amongst yourselves and had to
make this decision who made the final
decision what were the what was the
conversation like in the room the final
decision is president's decision so I
didn't which had final say on that and
well the situation was quite simple
because today is early morning we
learned about the decision of all
basically to close their skies and to
disallow flights starting from tomorrow
and there is no
frame for this decision - didn't know it
would be five days for away for ten days
eleven and we had to take this difficult
decision because you know carrying on
with a November when he was what it but
our main concern was the health concern
of theirs and here I think Lee did quite
a massive and quite a good work because
we tested them we all the medical
check-ups were like twice a day and
tests for coronavirus were twice this
formal wedding day of their violence and
the ends day they present and that was
our main concern we had to minimize any
context of the player with an outside
world we ban spectators it was a urinal
waste so for us it was priority which we
managed to take there's your environment
of course it was additional
psychological pressure never the west
but still but when it came to the
possibilities that players will finish
the tournament in ten days and then
found himself in Russia without knowing
when exactly they would be able to leave
the country or whether their own country
with local supporters him clears that
became plea as if we we have to take
some action of course we could
stubbornly go ahead with his defense a
sleep what's happened and there's me
it's pretty improves and fashionable
fades eyes or maybe after the tournament
civil state by sometime in Russia we've
Aries is Peron Fabiana said he's used to
be three months away but irresponsible
we knew that at the very beginning we we
took say the decision which was not say
assess risk understood as there is a
risk of tournament being in two parts
never our believes that Raj of Mother
Russia would be infected and his only
safe haven in this world the way we just
have to evaluate risks to see all the
pros and cons I think that the decision
we took 20 days ago was correct and we
couldn't foresee what's going on and I
put it also I mean if you compare it
even with the government's the even
government's change they oppose the
industry in in almost every country
fixing some government start with no non
reacting at all some some take very mild
steps and says they they make it much
more stricter so in our case of course
if this new decree has been published
with continued because of the health
point of view we managed to secure what
they were think the worst case barrier
didn't you realize at the beginning that
we remain everything no for that don't
minimize his presence but once again we
had to troll this positive power of
develop it by securing players and we
immediately took all the actions
required we change the tickets with
published posts we accompanies the
players we pulled all the possible
strings and sounds and already left
Ekaterinburg Moscow Moscow and for some
ourselves it's perfect by to take them
from directly so players are expected
all of them are expected Russia they in
Hope which night were all support and
they asked you Emil do you know why did
the Russian government give a reason why
it was that they decided to stop all air
travel i mean i can assume generally
speaking but they did give a specific
reason as to why they had to take that
action immediately
well I honestly don't find it very
logical this Oh course of action because
they didn't they didn't impose a strict
parent as a septa so they claim that the
most of Kate or nearly all the cases
came from pro and the situation keeps
getting worse and the first step which
should prevent any viruses coming from
outside and we will already tackle what
suppose in Valens I would say that this
would be in a small decision two weeks
ago but nowadays it seems to be a bit I
would say unbalanced decision because if
you don't pose a currently not on your
own country at the same time only only
using a lockdown it's not gonna help but
anyways we do not have an impact on
these decisions so once it's taken we
know that we have to be directed by the
situation which already occur I mean you
mentioned that you have previous
information and with that you decided
there were risks there are some factors
to take into consideration and you moved
on ahead decided candidates should be
done when you started the tournament
what was the percentage chance that you
thought this would actually come to our
completion well there was three points
through its three turning points at
retail if first was will then read job
upset and ultimatums at you it's either
we postpone or or he withdraws that was
on March 4 and by that time we evaluated
risk is very low maybe five percent at
that point with and at the beginning
when he raised this question we we
actually quite surprised because if you
take the situation on Mars real for once
- first off and just look at it back
because nowadays I mean with all this
changing every day you have an idea it's
like it was for ages here absolutely
different situation almost every place
except for let's say it's a way I'm
talking about here it was it was not
something that he put in doing that it
will get such a proportions
we felt that with a field of only eight
players it would take all the measures
and as I mentioned we really took it
very very seriously the risk is minimal
I mean it's it's really we we actually
thought that the risk is not that
somebody would be contracting the virus
but that we would be since there is a
minimum risks at some point don't hook
stop like what effectively happen now
would be really low any expectation it
was a second for evaluation we had to do
about that just before it warmed when
Russian Ministry issued a decree since
the events the supporter has to be
stopped
hours actually technically already
started legally started we were legally
okay to go with that possibility there
with validation and once again we saw
with us very likely that we would manage
to to navigate the tournament through
and there are several confidences a way
we saved our players the pinnacle to see
the age of the players say I mean yeah
is there no less I mean this is one
thing which I want to underline it
sometimes people even if it's about how
how brilliant and repeat of yesterday
was three journal published better very
important article item by two prophecies
of who actually claims that the response
is now being over taking over any
reasonable proportion CD check check
have a look at it because you know
nobody knows what what exactly what
exactly he is adventure you are the
fitted general director right now not a
medical expert we do kind of cater to
all a big audience I don't want people
saying well sitarski said you know this
is being blown out of proportion or Wall
Street Journal I mean chess you guys
made a risk decision it didn't pay off
the candidates did have to be
how do we move forward from here what
are the things that we do know are going
to happen in the future regarding the
tournament yeah we'll be finished
because it has to do something
it is obviously related to our decision
because nobody knows and I claimed it
again I don't I don't claim it is easy
it's taken out of person that says it
now but in else what because we don't
have even a clear statistic evidence
don't happen and we didn't have it 20
days ago though so we have to take this
so we had to evaluate risks and to see
how high is the probabilities that we
will manage to have this event or we
have to answer the decimal so we delayed
that the cancers habit are pretty high
the chances of divorce is we are
absolutely minimum of having there the
virus and a cancellation itself seemed
like a some say in between solution
which would not be desirable be bad
it is not likable but not likely to
happen but it's not something which
would be catastrophic help players so at
the point of we felt from the health
point of view effective we can go ahead
and we can secure all these things so we
went ahead now what's going to happen
now it's as simple as before we have to
pack of three immediate steps to get
players at home safely we have to make
sure that the body is you know oh man
and the event is terminated that's in a
good way not an erotic way and then we
make the thing what what was following
up I mean we obviously will continue
with the event because as was agreed
with every player I would want underline
it it was not like faded taking
authority of decision and you go and
play and you go and break every player
was informed written form and it was
agreed with and as long as they were
important with each other we have
correspondence all the players at the
meeting because the tournament both
would happen under every respect area
for example if it would happens at the
tournament it stopped by decree of
Russian authorities or if some player
pulls off the tournament because he just
feels uncomfortable and I just say that
we do have a lot of guests so we wanted
to express our appreciation thank you
very much for joining our stream our
show and letting us know the official
feed a position I know it's been very
very difficult a lot of demands on you
so thank you very much for your time and
sharing your thoughts with us best
wishes as well
yeah difficult situation thank you thank
you meal difficult situation and like
there was a collaboration though also
between the players at the end yeah the
players weren't informed for a lot of
different reasons what would happen if
the tournament does get postponed nobody
actually foresaw that determent would
get postponed for this reason a lot of
them had already been told what happened
if somebody got sick right
but pita as Emile was saying I was
taking all the precautions this is way
out of their hands yeah I mean country
closes its borders right is it's an
awkward situation to be sure now I
having said that we are hopeful yes to
have another guests join and many other
guests as well as we try to get our
ducks in a row and get the opinion of
those more knowledgeable experienced
veterans of the chess world we've seen a
few things I saw the conclusion when I
was a young man of the match between
Garry Kasparov and Anatoly Karpov that
was remarkable I mean you know you were
in a live alejandro it was remarkable it
was just like a stunning thing you
should stop it wasn't just the the match
itself concluding it was everything that
led to that all the controversy Fleur
Armani's was Karpov in in league with
the Russian authorities and Gary the
outsider as he was saying no I want to
keep playing look I just won two games
in a row why are you stopping this
it wasn't certainly for the health of
everyone involved or flight air charter
flights being canceled and the like but
certainly was one of the more remarkable
events to live through as well just as
this generation is living through this
is you know that the 9/11 those of us
who have and you were alive at 9/11 and
experiencing that as well this is what's
happening in the world today so
certainly remarkable answers and we do
now have five time world champion
Vishwanath on and on this she's welcome
to the show thank you so much for
joining us tell us your thoughts on this
incredible occurrence look in all my in
my life I've never experienced anything
like this and you constantly keep
telling yourself this feels like some
movie so particularly bad movie I mean
we've had diseases before and so on but
nothing on this scale attacking the
whole wall so we're getting used to new
ways of doing things every day and I
think in the end it's probably
inevitable that if it wasn't the air
restrictions it would have been
something else but they just had to
cancel the tournament because the
participants might simply not be able to
leave after tomorrow there was a pretty
divided line before the tournament
whether determined should happen or
shouldn't you were in some ways
supported that the tournament should
start do you think that the risk taken I
wouldn't want to care about a gamble the
risk taking by feeted to start the
tournament was correct of course
hindsight is 20/20 and all that but we
did have to stop the candidates
I think there was a kind of consensus
building but it took a while to by March
11th or 12th everyone was in agreement
that it should have been cancelled in
February but in February the thinking
wasn't that clear yet I think in a lot
of different countries around the world
we thought this was a regional problem
we thought there's some potential danger
I mean that's the way I saw it and of
course I'm influenced by the same news
articles that everyone reads and so on
so these terms were becoming familiar
but this concept of flattening this
curve which has now become the
expression of the year almost for us
that wasn't universally known back then
so yeah with hindsight they it should
never have started but maybe it was
impossible for PDA to have gone that far
ahead I mean as we say raja baath was
right but he was just early yeah what a
problem as a top player how do you feel
being would you be in Raja bows position
he made an ultimatum which is of course
difficult with a presidency like fita or
an organization like fidei and he was
right if you want to see it that way
perhaps he didn't go through the best
channels but he was right too early
isn't that a strange thing to be yeah I
mean I've heard this in the context of
markets that could be right but you can
be early I've never thought of it in
this sense but yes he was right equally
there were people I mean if we now speak
to a predominant Amala gist they seem to
have known three years ago that
something like this was possible so they
were really far ahead of the curve but
nobody was listening to them then they
feel like these profits that you just
ignore and so raja baath seems to be
incorrect also I'm not completely clear
about the ultimatums the stories
contradict Raja Bob says he didn't throw
it on the line or anything he just told
them look we really need to cancel and
he says he was given an ultimatum on the
twins that he had to sign by the 26th so
I'd need to understand exactly what
happened but I think he's the only one
who's really been harmed by this and in
a way that they cannot make right
you can't there is no way back for as
for the other participants I guess we
should be happy that it's over and that
they are still healthy right by the way
on that note Vichy where are you calling
from
I mean I'm in actually a Germany unable
to get a flight back home that was what
I wanted to say you've been stranded
yourself right yes well I came here and
stayed back a bit so that I could bridge
between two Bundesliga weekends and that
was the plan I was going to go back the
day after the Bundesliga weekend and
then my flight moved a few days and then
it just keeps moving point India
announcer it wouldn't allow any flights
from the European Union to land
I don't even maybe it's just total now
maybe they've just shut down all the
airports so we first need a pause to
reopen and I don't have my options are
getting pushed further and further I
mean if I land in some other city I
still face the problem of how to go from
Delhi or Bombay to Chennai so I think I
might actually end up waiting for a good
better connection because even if that
takes long at least I get home so
literally you yourself are stranded and
it's kind of ironic that fee day itself
has canceled the event because they were
worried of the players getting stranded
yeah I mean I'm quite lucky that I'm
able to stay in my flat but I don't
think the participants would have wanted
to stay in a hotel me Ekaterinburg
indefinitely
that's so yeah that's that's a
difference and maybe for the organizers
as well this was not an attractive
option so the hand got forced but I have
actually been generally supportive of
fadec going ahead at the event my
feeling was having come this far you
might hope see it through and once
players have started traveling then it's
just as risky for them to go back right
just to stay and so I but maybe I was
just happy to have some event to follow
maybe that's what it was
but you're right with hi with hindsight
things are getting clearer and they're
probably the lessons to learn for the
next time I'm not sure we could have
known in advance Vichy mass you're
you're the practicing player among us
right now you you're still very busy and
playing in tournaments as well you're
feeling as someone who was certainly
anticipating that chess was gonna get
played for the rest of the year now you
don't have any events to look at for the
foreseeable future as a practising
player how does that feel and if I may
also add on what do you think were the
thoughts how difficult was it for those
players to play at the site itself given
thank you which what do you think you
would have been feeling knowing all the
world events and issues with your family
and children back home okay the last
question first I think once the
tournament gets going you just go on
autopilot essentially from doing
something from doing an intense intense
mental activity which is playing
competitive chess I don't see much that
they did that they wouldn't have done in
quarantine at home except that they had
focused and something to do all day but
[Music]
now getting back to your first question
I don't know I'm like I said I've never
experienced anything like this and I
have no idea what to compare it with but
here I might have I might have the whole
year free this also means that you
stopped working because if something is
too far into the future it's too
abstract it's like training for a match
three years from now why would you do it
so but nonetheless the last few days I
have managed to impose some discipline
if you like and I'm trying to stick to
some kind of schedule for the day just
not to go crazy because otherwise days
just rolled by and you have to feeling
or doing nothing so I'm trying to
organize myself a bit and you know make
some time for the family calls make some
type of work learn some new things
whatever so I understand you completely
because while you're in yourself
isolation we also here in st. Louis were
also in self isolation and the
tournament itself was arrest
for us it gave us something to look
forward to something to analyze
something to comment upon and it was
really something we look forward to and
wow we're just kind of reeling ourselves
because we haven't really come to grasp
what it means and well we're just
reeling and you've seen the pictures all
the empty cities on in the world I mean
go cities yeah I mean we can actually go
and see it but it's I don't know says
Chennai is the quite a city in the world
thank you so much for joining us and
sharing your thoughts it's really an
extraordinary time and we wish you well
and your family as well I hope you get
home quickly and safely thank you thank
you bye bye
Wow Thank You Vicki for joining us I
mean I knew he had been stranded of
course the bundesliga and it is really
ironic that you know India closed its
airspace
prior to Russia closing its airspace so
he can really identify with the players
be in it empathetic towards their
situation write a difficult situation
all around
well let's see if we have any more news
about what's going on Maurice do you
have anything no nothing breaking just
yet I just want to say it's incredible
you see someone like vision on who's
been playing chess the better part of
his life and he must have been looking
forward to many events coming in the
future a studying chess that's that's
the lifeblood and passion when you want
to thought on Iran say I just don't feel
like studying like I I don't have
anything to look forward to then you
know what's happening in our profession
right now quite a sad thing and you look
forward to those great moves of the
great players that's what our whole
lives have been devoted to those
wonderful novelties who's winning in
what events when does Magnus Carlsen
play next for example all those
questions that make us have joy to have
this sport as our activity that we've
devoted our lives to and now to see
this happened is pretty remarkable I
should also point out for myself
my family's in New York I have children
there I have relatives there certainly a
lot of friends and New York is quite the
epicenter of what's happening in the
world in the u.s. right now and some
scary times in the city so after this
it's New York for me so this is truly
one of those challenges that everybody
has to face exactly Wow we don't want to
see you going right into the epicenter
of well where the virus has really
emerged but we do have a great color
it's our friend Leonard Otis from
Yekaterinburg I think I'm actually not
sure where he is right now
better where are you right now how did
you pronounce you Catrin Burke just go
on with the show
the same way every last name I'm silly
in Russia I'm Sonya Burke I'm still in
my room I'm showing the house over the
tournament is played and plans to leave
yeah so when the news broke this morning
that all the flights will be canceled
from tomorrow we of course had to find a
solution okay first orbit was canceled
and then how do we get home and there
were two options either to to get like a
commercial flight and her were like I
could take a flight at 3 p.m. to Moscow
and then onwards to Amsterdam where I
live or I could rely on fidei which is
the adventurous situation and and fit I
arranged a private jet from
Yekaterinburg to Amsterdam which will
bring about nine or I would say like
nine people to safe havens and those
includes Maxim and F Abbi
mm-hmm they will be on the same flight
to Amsterdam and then Maxine will go to
Paris and I think I thought we will
finally fly back home as well
yeah Fabi has a flight to Detroit on the
next day
what about some of the other players
where assume the Russians should have no
problems getting home have believed at
one house going to Tokyo have you heard
anything about ding li Ren no declaring
it's one of the few people I did not see
today because he was staying in a
different hotel I am sure he's on his
way to Beijing or something but I have
not heard any confirmation my competitor
is an ish he chose to to take the
commercial flights so I think it's
flights about to to take off now
actually from Moscow he already reached
Moscow Moscow and yeah so he will be
home very soon as well difficult
situation for sure when exactly did you
guys hear about this and what was the
first thing you did well
I up and before I went to breakfast I
was scrolling on my timeline and somehow
I saw this message on the timeline that
Russian flights were cancelled and I
think that was before other people knew
about it
so then I informed other people and
determined organization about it and and
I asked a music Sasuke like hey hey
what's going on and I had my breakfast
plans and just waited for for fear to
cancel the event and I know from that
point on I I knew the only thing I can
do is to get back home
Leonard it sounded we had a meal on
earlier before you joined us but he he
made it sound like it was a
collaboration that the players agreed
with the decision that was being taken
and so on do you know about that
no well actually actually I don't think
the players are much info because I rec
fost I knew I knew it already for half
an hour two flights were canceled I saw
Maxime and I told him like do you think
the France will what happened today and
he misheard me said yeah I'm playing
Fabi what news and we know that like
yesterday Putin he spoke to the to the
people on life on TV
and he did not mention anything about
the flights so there was no he did not
announce or lock down the main the main
thing that he announced was that like
the next elections about his neck new
privileges to stay longer as the
president this elections will be
postponed there was like his clique the
main main point of him talking to the
people and exporting they canceled it
out of nowhere
Chris Leonard what mentioning that is
you're following Russian news you're
there on the spot what was what is the
situation in Russia as far as you know
it's been announced in terms of the
illnesses there and why with such a
radical decision as this one be taken
precisely I say radical of course other
places are doing it as well but why
precisely at this time that's pretty big
news yeah it's me there are well I can i
when I read about a news in Russia I
mainly follow a newspaper or like a
website it's called Moscow today I
believe and they're try to be more
independent and from today there were
like eight hundred something cases and
two people who died however you trust
Russian numbers and I think the answer
should be by default no we should not
trust those numbers but the situation in
Moscow is of course different from
situation here because like we're more
more East I send Moscow if it would
start in Russia it should be somewhere
in Moscow that's where people stuck
together in the subways and where most
of the big life is going on you know
this is a big city and hearing your
Katrine Burke I had a feeling that there
were less people on the streets then a
week ago the buses were a little bit
less back than a week ago but at the
same time I did not feel a big chaos a
few very few people on the streets were
wearing masks of course in our hotel
everybody had to wear masks so all the
employees of the hotel had to wear a
mask
but like outside of this outside of the
hotel I hardly felt any any concerns or
whatever first of all before I forget
this is very very important Leonard I
did want to get in a big shout out and
thank you for all the marvelous work
that you have been done been doing
getting the players on our show and very
much your photo photographs I think you
do fantastic work it's just absolutely
wonderful
I really we all do appreciate what
you're doing and I wanted to get that in
absolutely with a big thank you
yeah for sure know what time do you
leave what well you're as a hotel right
now I already have the feeling like
you'd be at the airport yeah why are you
still in your room yeah so like I was in
the lobby I would say like five hours
ago with my suitcases packed ready to go
but then they told us that the private
jet that we will have will leave the
airport around 11:00 p.m. that's one
hour be fair right right
Yeah right yes however it shuts down
midnight but I guess it's Moscow time
two hours time difference with Moscow so
right now it is almost seven o'clock and
yesterday here I see what is the weather
like is it clear skies shouldn't be a
problem traveling I think the weather is
kind of adopting with the news it's been
a very gray and sad day in the past few
days it has been like very blue blue sky
it has been like around freezing points
so I don't have to convert any Celsius
or Fahrenheit there but like it's it was
it was cold but like it was uh it was
like a nice Sun and stuff but like today
it has been very cloudy I'm looking
outside the window right now beautiful
fuel over Lake and a Cathedral and I can
see that like some part of the river is
still frozen and two days ago I saw
people actually crossing the river which
I think it's kind of like a suicide
attack attempt but those people survived
but I wouldn't do it now the ice looks
more fragile than two days ago
nice we wish you the best getting home
thanks so much for joining us and all
the fantastic work we do my friend I
can't wait to see you again it's some
chess event we always meet somewhere in
sorry like where will we see each other
again
we will because you've probably gotten
the chance to ask the question did the
players how did the players feel
themselves about well just playing the
second half later in the year did you
get any feedback on that point I think I
think like people were more concerned
about getting their flights back of
course like the Russians right they know
they have nowhere to go anywhere okay I
mean they're not affected by this travel
ban we shook he was happy because he
already predicted it he plays a bet and
someone actually took the bet of him so
he 100 euros there was kind of like I
would say reliefs but like everybody
almost to the situation I don't have any
direct quotes and actually what Fabi
said in his tweets maybe you discussed
that bit already what's very very
sensitive because I also for me it was a
way to escape all the corona fibers news
and and I was very safe and happy here
and from tomorrow on I will be and
intervals reality I'm not happy about
that
exactly well stay safe inside exactly
yeah
so sighs by Leonard well guys to recap
no tournament until a later date we
don't know that date yet there's Mark
the players that will continue the
rounds will continue as planned right
between these players and with this
court that they
only half we are going to have former
world champion garry kasparov later with
us on the show you'll be joining us yet
about half an hour or so I mean it
almost feels like I absolutely want to
look at chances really you know like
light like it's ridiculous but because
this is a situation you know we're gonna
not look at Jeff's for a moment but
we're gonna take a call from Omaha yes
well welcome to the show and please give
us our question name hey this is Carlos
from Omaha how y'all doing today
just refer [ __ ] weird Carlos how are
you doing fantastic stands things good
my life has just been like taken away no
chance for whatever I thought I'm
curious with with all of these things
surrounding you know tournaments and
everything is there any thought for like
how they played like the pro chess where
you can play them the latter of seven
rounds you know via Skype or whatever
the case may be
seems to be a free interesting idea but
how would they organize that but I'm
just curious of your thoughts on that
yeah Carlos first of all thank you for
the question very insightful and a good
one jump right in the answer is 0%
chance it's not good it's not gonna
happen we will not have the tournament
online there are many reasons for that
but among the main ones we're not
talking about cheating which obviously
are concerns we could deal we can deal
with that we can have fede officials at
the side in front of the player it's not
the same game it really does boil down
to that it's not the same game people
don't feel that playing chess over the
board and playing chess online is the
same type of tournament this is an over
the board tournament that started over
the board and will finish over the board
when how in which location that's going
to be different but the tournament will
not be held online that is not an idea
that is being entertained interesting
the only one that I really recall is
Bobby Fischer yes he was invited to Cuba
to play in a tournament and an
invitation he accepted but then he was
refused travel permission and he played
by teletext
which was really a bizarre thing and
there he was the only one at the
Marshall chess club while everybody else
was in Havana playing the normal
tournament he was literally absent now I
could imagine it happening in the way
that Carlos had asked the question and
praying the question but that would only
happen if the really the covet virus
lasted for many many a month I mean we
saw there earlier in the show that Vijay
is concerned that they want to have a
challenger for the Dubai event in
December and they would need that happen
months in advance oh yeah it just
happened personally gotten a lot of
emails about rescheduled events
specially small opens little things that
for example continental chasis
organizing and somehow they all seem to
happen in September it seems that there
is like everything gets crashed somebody
came up with the global consensus I
don't know who it was that everything
was gonna be rescheduled in September
and if you see the list of tournaments
now in September it's huge really
apparently a lot of people decided that
moon is more or less when it's going to
be safe to reschedule something for even
the protesting speaking of them before
they're rescheduled their finals for the
final for their final four for September
as well so it's looking like we're gonna
have to wait until that side of the year
here in st. Louis of course we were
going to be here in the month of April
for the US Championship yeah that
tournament got postponed and the
thinking that I heard was July or
October July a very different date
because even in July we already have a
very packed schedule if it happens right
if we happens we have the juniors
championship we have the senior
championship as well here at the club
right it would be difficult to clash
with them because the junior does
qualify to the championship so it's an
important event independent of the other
but a lot of questions not a lot of
answers plenty of months could be
candidates for the candidates but I'm
not entirely sure when would be
good time to say this will be over by
then we know yeah it's impossible it's
impossible it's literally impossible to
say we're hearing news by the minute and
often by the but you think by the week
by the day by the hour
everything is breaking right now I'm
with a lot of you guys no chess no
hibbity for months and months
I mean I'm somebody who you know I was
thinking about going into the streaming
world I said oh that's gonna be too much
time you know doing it now I got a lot
of time might be streaming in the next
few months it's crazy the the rich
content that we love and we follow in
our game you know we were very fortunate
to have this as our as our sport as our
activity as it as our livelihood and I
know there are many in the world right
now
who are worried just about making a
living in all the gig workers who are
not able to go to work or the the actors
and the waiters and the people who work
for sporting events as well some sad
news in the sports world at the moment
as karl-anthony towns the big man for
the Minnesota Timberwolves basketball
team his mom is in a medically induced
coma right now and they think from
complications from the virus and he did
tweet about the difficulties his family
actually posted a video about the
difficulties his families is going
through as they suffer through this
actually his father also contracted what
looks like the virus as well but he got
over it and now they're just waiting on
their mom so shout out to him and his
family as well as we simply cannot tell
the future we just have to do everything
right folks and what authorities are
saying we should do social distancing
washing your hands definitely hunker
down we're all in this together and what
we do matters to everyone else Thank You
Maurice now all we're gonna do is we are
gonna take a break but we're definitely
definitely coming back and don't worry
garry kasparov is actually standing by
and we will get him on our show as well
The Situation's very fluid please don't
go away yeah we'll be right back don't
go anywhere
want to thank you all for joining us
today for what is certainly an historic
moment we're privileged at ascension to
have a mission with a capital M and it's
who we are and it's about giving back to
the community it's a win for the
Champions Tour and our players it's a
win for the fans and the spectators
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience st. Louis University
celebrating its 200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of San Luis Slough attracts
students and professors from around the
globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Luis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
Peace inception SLU obtained second best
university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to to 2020 candidates
it is not around eight however as the
tournament has been postponed to an
indefinite time in a different location
we do know the standings we do know that
these are the players that will move on
with the amount of points that they have
right now
exactly but right now those players are
scrambling to get home they're not
worried about their openings they're not
worried about who they're playing they
are trying to get home as Russia has
closed we'll be closing its borders very
very soon and in a few hours actually
exactly I think you have it max even
share the graph on Yahoo poetry leave
Yekaterinburg with four and a half
points out of seven putting them
temporarily in first place and a bunch
of hungry wolves know they're gonna have
some time to prepare and those hungry
wolves are all at 50% it's rather ironic
to look at the standings realizing only
two players actually have a plus score
in the whole event this is rather
unusual very tightly packed field but
yes this is it the first half of the
tournament is officially in the history
books second and half of the tournament
to be determined to be played we're
really kind of reeling by all of the
events that have happening today but
we're very happy also to have with us
Christian Corolla on the line Christian
are you as shocked as we are how is it
going guys I had some time to adjust I
was actually awake around 3:30 when when
I saw it popping up on Twitter so you
know I went to sleep I assumed there
will be no show today but it seems like
you guys are still working so yes yeah
well we've got so much to discuss how
the decision was made why it came about
in the way it did happen
players scrambling to leave lots and
lots of unanswered questions in a very
fluid situation and then the hurt that
our distraction our recipe that we were
getting from all of the self-isolation
is being ripped away from us that we
don't get to enjoy Jess
for today and for tomorrow that's very
very hurtful that's painful it's it's
very difficult for all the chess players
out there that were counting on the
candidates but I think it's the right
decision I think they were supposed to
do this from the beginning now the big
question remains what's going to happen
right job oh it seems like it's going to
continue with the same players after
seven rounds and then who knows when
yeah the question is also when are we
going to have a world championship at
the end of the year as of now it looks
unlikely so so many questions so many
questions so we saw a tweet definitive
tweet in the fact that stated One world
champion Magnus Carlsen said he said
there may have been an argument for
Rishabha for this tournament but
certainly not for 2022 he doesn't think
that's a good idea at all I think a lot
of people are saying well maybe there
should be an option right now to include
him in the proceedings your thoughts
there no I think at this point the
players are pretty much set it would be
very unfair for MDL to just like doing
180 and then and get her a job oven I
think pitas decision was made at the
beginning they should be ready for
whatever Roger Bobb is going to throw at
them because I wouldn't be happy if I
would be at his place
so we're going to have to wait and see
Padilla for 2022 Roger was ready to play
this year
what Roger would probably spend the last
two three months in training camp paying
trainers training you know paying
seconds and whatnot so his losses are
immeasurable at this point also his
psychological losses are immeasurable
it's very difficult to do that and then
people pretty much mocking you at some
point yeah like what's happening here
why are you withdrawing so he's in a
difficult situation but I'm sure
everything will be sorted out well we
saw a tweet from him actually earlier
where he says I have no
words yeah I definitely not the type of
versus he's with Amy also tops character
I am pretty much anything but this
decision to continue the candidates from
the beginning I do sympathize with what
you're saying by the time this decision
was made right it did seem that a lot of
sporting events were being canceled
because it was huge gatherings right
that a lot of things that were big and
needed to be toned down than though they
couldn't happen by the time a lot of
decisions were made have a good
tournament of eight players on an
arbiter that you can monitor in a place
that has not really been affected by
that point right it didn't seem at that
point to be crazy I mean a lot of people
thought this isn't basket players are
literally next to each other you know
pressing against one another
you can practice social distancing
between the players and so on and a lot
of a lot of people that saw Roger Bose
think a lot of them saw them yeah this
is foresight the sternum and will
eventually be canceled but I don't think
that was the majority thought dr. Waymon
yeah at that moment it wasn't look at
just admit those moments I was making my
flight plans to come here it wasn't my I
mean I was thinking that I'm coming here
for two events actually I was coming
here for the candidates tournament I was
coming here to one of my favorite
tournaments I US Championships yeah so I
was looking forward to seeing so many of
my friends and by the time I literally
got on my plane I was beginning to have
doubts a double guessing like the doubt
started as the tournament began and they
just grew day by day by day to the point
where today it seemed ridiculous to us
organize such an event but at that
moment at that moment it just was not
the case yeah yeah I think it was March
5th or 6th when he announced his his
withdrawal and then by the time March 13
March 14 it was already pretty clear
that things are going to be
very rough and yeah I mean we'll see
what's going to happen only time will
tell
it seems that he does have a quote I did
read something on another chess site
that he has insisted that he should be
put back in the tournament now really at
this and that's remarkable given that
seven rounds have been played already
started he didn't say what then he wants
to restart he just wants to be included
was the quote this break is good for I
think for Napa and never was definitely
having some difficult times after his
loss against Bashir log raft and we know
that he is a very good very fast order
and very slow finisher now if he starts
a second event who knows you know maybe
he's going to start with plus three
again I think it's good news for Napa
for sure what about the other players
you've worked with Fabiana Caruana
himself you must have been surprised at
how he was doing in this event so far
given that he was the top seed do you
think that he'll be able to come back
from the deficit very difficult to say I
mean he's he's a known enough type of
player if he's in shape he can easily
score plus three plus four
obviously this tournament he he was a
bit hesitant and it showed during his
games but if he plays a tournament like
he did in Tata Steel earlier this year
then I see him catching up with a leader
so show yourself what about the players
at the end the tail end you're Kirilenko
you're ding Lauren you're two points
behind you mathematically it's gonna be
difficult to come back from that score
do you think I'm saying they will even
want to finish the event and are they
obligated would if they said you know
what I don't want to apply anymore you
guys finish it it's a very difficult
decision and I don't know how they will
take the decision is it going to be a
vote by by the players you know I think
in the Premier League they stopped the
Premier League and Liverpool is like 20
points ahead but now all all the teams
are voting where
whether they want to continue the season
or just cancel the season altogether so
you know they're counting votes right
now we'll see how they're going to
handle this situation
Peter that is that's insane you see a
match between guys a match between the
players in first and second deciding it
may be because I'm sure that ball is not
gonna vote never was not gonna vote
right now numbers that we have to
concede because if you stop right now
maxime is in right yep I don't imagine
the players will want to stop anyway
Richard not Fabi you got to feel like
they're in range
they're so close there's as well in fact
why how was well one one point in
several rounds is not such a huge
deficit know it can be raising one one
game pretty much Christian we want to
thank you as always for joining us and
also for the work you do with the counts
corner keeping us entertained stay safe
sanitize and until we meet again right
thank you guys
Wow and once again for those of you who
are joining us late we do expect that
Garry Kasparov will join us to get to
share his thoughts on this twenty twenty
candidates and the stoppage for those of
you are joining us late there's a bit of
mad scramble for the foreign players to
get out of Russia players and seconds
and officials as well as creative
talents such as Leonard who well does
have a flight now right but that is the
tail end that is the last flight they
can get on by the way let's just do a
shout out because it sounded like that
that was a specially chartered flight
that yes Vijay had arranged so we have
to thank Vijay for doing that and
stepping in these very very unusual
circumstances so it's extremely unusual
I like what getting what Vichy and non
said I mean look this is a man who's
been around you know he's seen a lot of
tournaments in his life and I just said
like nothing nothing in my experience
comes close well that is the situation
that we're handling right now I mean of
course
sideline commentators for us it's
shocking and we're
trying to get all the news to you guys
as players to just can't imagine not
only participating in the event but
right now with this mad scramble of how
to get home which flights to get seeing
if they're delayed a little bit of panic
imagine that you are right now sitting
in your Qatar where you look at the sky
it's great and you know that if this
flight is canceled you're stuck in
Russia yeah that's it who knows how long
right with a few hours yeah absolutely
are very very difficult that's to me
that would be the first thing and you
know the future to think about of course
no chess for a while what what will
competitive chess look like but the
immediate concern right now is the
players and officials and everyone
involved getting back to their friends
and families where they wish to be at a
time like this to hunker down and ride
this out and so we'll be seeing very
very soon whether or not all that plays
itself out in the next few days well
it's a real snap you know you go from
you know suffering with your French
defense whenever one moment to like did
I pack everything got my flight 9 fo
never won't have that problem never can
get home yeah he's already home
basically true that let's take a look at
how the players got to this point in
time in their tournaments and again the
standings are frozen the first half is
in we'll start with Bingley right well
he's currently sitting in last place
without like saying oh not where we
thought we would seek him not at all
this is a man that Gary said it's 5050
between favi
and Bingley Aaron and the rest of the
feel actually set three to one exactly
yeah this man and fabbi and he'll give
you the field started with two losses
absolutely shocking but then he beats
the number one seed I mean it's amazing
but unfortunately we're really went off
was in round six that was when he lost
against yan and that basically sealed
the deal in my view this really sealed
the deal how determined gone on I didn't
think you can psychologically come back
from that two points and seven rounds is
still really really tough even in the
best psychological chess shape of your
world I I don't see him coming back from
this one no one does and then we take a
look at the wild card see here I think
Carol has done relatively well he
started solid I mean okay you did he did
lose against karana with black but guess
what losing to karana with black is
something that can happen to anybody
number two player in the world one again
that round six on each Garry he played
agree he played a tough game he played a
tough defense he didn't need to get to
that position but once I did he did hold
it very well until that those last
seconds of the game where he just oiled
an easy drop exactly so that's why he's
languishing in this tie for seventh and
eight and then we come to our 50% group
this is a strange one one how who could
have more points no kidding man thing
he's giving ending the red scintillating
he had a uncomfortable position but one
mistake by his compatriot and one cow
was all over that position when a very
nice game with black he's winning in
round two just completely winning
against Geary an extra pawn just a
technical conversion doesn't get it done
lets him escape and suddenly he's tied
for first instead of being the clear
leader absolutely meanwhile it's Fabiano
Carwin another person that people
thought he was gonna be leading but not
so much he hasn't got itself included -
forming a cat I'm working you go find it
somewhere else because right now he is
on his way to st. Louis where he lives
and hopefully he'll have the time to
recover psychologically because it
didn't feel that he was playing at his
best he starts the tournament with a
draw against MBL where he was a bit
better
he destroyed Alex anko and that loss
against England just felt like it was
huge
it really really was and that prepper a
losing in your preparation and that was
some scintillating scourged scorching
preparation to
but that really really hurt ding played
maybe one of the best tournaments oh one
of the best games of the tournament
so there's fabbi at 50% yeah meanwhile
50% is also obvious
Yeary who I've been feeding Alexander
was able to get back to 50% since he did
lose that brilliant came to Nippon
Miyaichi at the very stern either very
started speaking of loosing in your
preparation yes and there was another
case where a really well-prepared player
was upended not only losing the
preparation but losing the whole point
by the way
onigiri explaining that in round six
this heart nearly skipped a beat as
after two candidates tournaments one
which is scored to draw and everyone was
his first victory in the candidate so
he's doing a couple more if he actually
wants to qualify to challenge - crossing
but with that victory he's only one
point ahead of meppel anova VL so behind
yeah yeah alright and and then we come
to our final player at 50%
Alexander Griffith one of the great
interviews of the tournament I must say
great interviews are never afraid to
speak his mind
he was the one that said I thought at
the beginning I was ambivalent now it
cleared the tournament has to be stopped
and the terminal was not stopped for
health reasons it was stopped for
something completely different but
related and it just felt that he was not
really wanting to be there exactly made
it very clear but it's just it was still
strong he made a bunch of drawers none
of them particularly questionable except
maybe that one against mvl you know it
seems like obviously he was thrown off
the game of his game he did use a word
and I found that really intriguing he
said he felt like the environment had
turned hostile a lot of the people
wearing masks and that that made an
impression upon me the only player to be
undefeated and to have no victory as
well drawn all of his games now you
could draw himself out of the tournament
but as we know there will be a second
half and that brings us to our to turn
Kalidas Janna for me Archie what a story
tournament in this man's had he was
absolutely brilliant in the first game I
guess a nice fury has just started off
amazing and then those two convincing
victories against the Chinese players
against Wang Hao and against and England
very was only he was the only player
winning when nobody else could and it
was practicing social distancing he had
a one-point lead going into that round
seven game last year and be out thought
it was critical but not absolutely
needed as it turned out well that was
the other time absolutely key game
because it is a tie but remember that
tie break now favors and the L ever so
slightly because the head-to-head is the
first I break that we're gonna be using
and speaking with a man himself
he is currently technically leading the
tournament even though they are tied for
first because of that last round victory
against uniform yah-tchi
that being said it is a tight tournament
half a point more that nipple can get
somewhere either by throwing we're in
via loses that's gonna be huge the
upcoming game I don't know if it's gonna
be in a month in three months it's gonna
be in November but the upcoming game
that Maxime has will be against Fabio
Khurana
so Fabi has months to prepare against
mvl Snyder for groom filter whatever it
is he chooses to take down what would be
a huge matchup because remember if Bobby
wins he catches a real right as we can
see here in the standings I don't like I
just actually passes him because of the
head to head again exactly and the
number of losses our number wins are all
is the second time again that also will
be favoring Fabiano karana exactly so a
lot to look forward to we don't know
where we don't know when Maurice but
those players how they got here a very
eventful tournament I'm sad that it's
not continuing it's really a quite
shocking indeed all of us who were
enjoying some respite from the news you
know how tough it is you're sitting at
home and you don't want to turn it on
but then you turn it on because you want
to be updated on what's going on but
then at some point you got to turn it
off right but then you don't because
there's more news coming in and as news
comes in from all over the world about
the difficult times that people are
facing everywhere it's hard and and then
the break you get is some good chests
some exciting game something fun to
watch something different to do to keep
folks entertained and now that's no
longer going to happen as well so yeah
it is definitely a sad day for chess I
think in the history of chess as well
this is something that just doesn't
happen every day something suddenly gets
stopped with that match we reference
Garry Kasparov and Anatoly Karpov they
had to stop their match after months of
play as the International Chess
Federation is president at the time for
inferential compromises the Philippines
came in and said we're stopping this
this is not going to go any further it's
taking too long
the health of the players are concerned
the fans are not watching anymore it's
just too many games too long months and
months and they ended up replaying it
several months later and Garry Kasparov
became the world champion you gotta go
much further back to find something like
this happening that the last one who we
can find is Mannheim 1914 before the
outbreak of World War 1 and a young
Alexander Deccan was declared the winner
no further play no rearrangement of any
kind and that was a big decision then of
course as well so we're seeing something
absolutely historic in the world of
chess for sure on a smaller private note
I do remember there was a competition
Linares Spain and a certain moment that
tournament had split into two venues
Mexico and then Linares Spain Timor raja
baath was playing in Morelia Mexico and
his hotel room was burglarized and lots
got stolen that story
and he was so distraught that he had
lost all of his files all of his
analysis he didn't continue the second
half of the tournament he would ask for
compensation for the laptop as well yeah
$1,000 yep because of all of his but I
mean is Roenick that team war happened
to be involved with that tournament did
go on they replace him with vasilyev on
sugar it's that correctly that's right
and another reason why I really didn't
upset the the tournament is actually
stopped because we had such a decisive
event full we had it was from 28 games
how many decisive games never good oh
great I mean the quality of some of the
drawers were site was absolutely
thrilling some of the games themselves
we didn't have a boring round I just
pulled up this game from yesterday
because I mean we could talk about the
games of the tournament because this has
been some really really good games in
this tournament but you know the more
you look at this particular game and I'm
of course I'm referring to MPL versus
Yann I mean MBL played so well all of
his Trump's in his position and the move
that I really appreciated
great was rookie four in 96 I
fortunately can't see my boy hey that
rookie 496 wasn't that just great
absolutely well we were here watching
the MV I'll pull that together
the main problem had been that tassels
is not possible illegal right well no a
long time ago the move Queen g4 had been
played rook to g8 and after Bishop e5
check King to f8 so already castling was
simply illegal on both sides of the
board on one side on this side first and
then on the other after the king move so
much later when this move route before
occurred you think well just Castle dude
you know you're okay if you saw this
position for the first time you would
have to be prompted I'm sorry it's
illegal to Castle because some moves
mean the work actually went back to h8
to stop the penetration of the Queen at
some point and the King moved back to EA
it was on a March trying to get to this
side when this magnificent move wrote
or appeared at Knight to c6 f4 saying
you can have my rook if you want to of
course Knight takes pawn takes would
have left this beautiful part thanks
Luke takes is disastrous to Queen c3
winning material and so you would have
to move your queen and then these pawns
would become very strong indeed a Bishop
to b4 and Knight to c3 the breakthrough
with f5 would be overwhelming so rook
before as you mentioned you has a
sterling move of many he actually ended
up playing but this was definitely the
start of the downhill trend in the
position for black and mvo rising to the
occasion
this victory giving him the lead in the
tournament from a technical standpoint
as though they're tied he does have a
tie break over the person he defeated so
far in the event is co-leader young in
the partnership well I tell you that was
really a great turning point here's some
tweets that we think are worth sharing
wow this is big one this was a big one
Roger chest that's a table right down
with the bounce rumours that he wasn't
motivated to play defeated candidates
revealing that he was thoroughly
preparing with grandmasters to chill off
we knew that one karaoke we knew that as
well a linear Dominguez who was one of
Lobby seconds in the 2018 candidates was
now working with Rodolfo I actually did
know this information but I didn't know
that it was MIT public it was just me
now within the last hour or so I mean
news of breaking and there's more more
news as well as we reveal here sometimes
I can foresee things this was much
easier for me to calculate general
information was enough to understand
that you are not running this event
which was very easy to suspend compared
to bigger sporting events that of course
is rajab of as well speaking directly
through twitter at raja chess well the
fact that he prepared nobody is doubting
he never paired hard we actually knew
that Kuryakin was part of his team quite
a while ago Dominguez was like a later
edition but he was preparing he was
preparing hard it was certainly not an
easy decision for him to say look I'm
not playing yeah I think
there's been a lot of talk on the
internet about a Java not wanting to
play he's definitely a player that
doesn't play chess as much as others
he's not as act he's not essential
active players yet but in fact in fact I
might add when he qualified after
beating Maxime yeah the day that
qualified the immediate moment just
right after he was interviewed and his
feelings that we was asked you know
you've qualified for the candidates are
you happy about that and he said well
I'm not even sure I would play yeah
which was like way way come on that's
that is that tongue-in-cheek why would
you say something like that it's just
kind of weird as you said ironic that
later it turns out that he doesn't end
up playing but it's but it wasn't the
case clearly he was preparing very very
hard for this and the fact that you do
have to take money out your pocket to
pay people to come work for you over
that time period
I mean that's real that's a real loss of
concrete loss not just the psychological
professional loss and and the the
depression he must be feeling for not
being able to participate in an event
that we all dreamt about as kids right
we want to be world champion you don't
want to become a grandmaster you when we
come world champion and some point you
realize how it's not gonna happen but
that's what you dream about and he was
this close he could have been
participating in the event yeah of
course travel but that wouldn't be his
first rodeo he did play in the 2013 so
he knows how grueling this ordeal is he
knows how to prepare he knew what it
takes and I think at the beginning when
he qualified he had the sudden
realization man I'm going through all
this again but he went through the
psychological process he sat down he
worked hard I know that when rajamma
works in chess
he's an incredibly creative and hard
worker
right and I would have loved to see what
he brought to the tournament
unfortunately lots of things happen and
this is the situation we are right now a
lot of Internet
talk about rajala being included I
really don't see that happening I don't
see any avenue for this to happen he
just not gonna include him not in the
cycle and I can't imagine them just
giving him a free pass in the next one
either
well we just got that very sharply
worded comment by Magnus Carlsen yes
champion about his potential inclusion
in 2020 and
I was really shot down by Magnus he just
didn't think that that was gonna happen
well we will see we're just standing by
waiting for garry kasparov
to join us so for those of you are
waiting yes we're happily waiting with
you as well
for Gary incite as to this very historic
eventful day I want to know his opinions
I mean was there the man when it all
happened this was before I was born so I
don't have anything to compare this to I
have never heard of a major event being
canceled in the middle of it just going
on top of it we're job of are they born
in the same city Yeah right both of them
were born in Baku so as you might have
something to say about that as well
about this player who certainly is a
tremendous player I just I just can't
imagine that guys I keep coming back to
the idea that it's not gonna be any more
chess for quite some time no I mean
that's that's a hard thing to realize we
kind of we're living in a bubble almost
we we're getting the last bit of chess
to digest and enjoy over this past week
or so a bit more than a week and now for
the foreseeable future none of the great
moves being played and people are
getting older as well let's deal with
that you know you two years from now is
a long time away for some players who
might have wanted to get their chance
now and so this is this is incredible to
me this that this has happened from a
historic perspective and and again this
is not just in chess this is in sports
this might have been this might have
been the last year the retirement year I
mean Vince Carter was in his retirement
year in basketball
everybody was feting him as he went out
to get to watch him will that come back
is they just gonna now just fade and and
say yeah I'm not gonna come back next
year guys because I already retired and
the baseball player as a sporting world
the Olympics as we mentioned that's been
a year I mean a year away as an athlete
who's been preparing rigorously right
now and somebody says shut it all down
you're not doing anything else
the irony are there to Murray so what
you're saying is like what if I go back
to
and the end of the Grantchester if and
then you know the start at the Karen's
cup I'm saying to myself this is the
Golden Age of chess the chess players
never had it so good there was so many
competitions and great prize funds and
fidei just announced that instead of a 1
million dollar world championship match
it was going to be a two million dollar
so you know 2020 starting it was such
extraordinary pilot promise and then
just as Murray says you're shutting
everything down like vicious and they're
saying hey man he's Jeremy because he
wanted to play the back-to-back weekends
of the Bundesliga that's of course the
German chess League which is the easily
the strongest chess league in the world
right perhaps outside of the Russian
chess league and that's not happening
right not just that all of the
livelihood that a lot of these players
depend on of course we talk about Vichy
but you know vision will be fine he made
his money in the grand Chester and all
these other events and World
Championships there's a lot of players
that live paycheck to paycheck and
disease in Europe right now that can
travel because there's no cheque league
there's no Greek league there's no
Spanish League League and you keep going
on how many players will decide not to
do chess anymore because serious thing
they can't afford it it doesn't make any
sense
to continue because for months you're
not gonna be playing any chess and what
what should you do at a time like this
is gonna be a lot of consideration by
the way speaking of that you those
events the Karan's Cup you mentioned
there was also the feed a women's Grand
Prix yes because that was it that was
actually taking place while all the
people were calling for the finish of
this event those women were fighting it
out duking it out and eventually a one
Venera by humpy canary no one won here
Karen squishy won but I'm talking about
the Grand Prix in the Grand Prix the
feed a women's Grand Prix where am i
drawing a blank so I need so on it with
coriaci yeah that's right it sounds like
Nixon who want it that's right yeah she
wanted a break so recording optimally
equals 30 yes right god that one so that
is Mya
right so so Zach ninja without event and
she I mean all the women who are saying
a surge in women's chest this is the
year of women's chest a lot of activity
at the Karen's copy of the Grand Prix
the Women's World Championship in
January they played for the biggest
prize fund ever for the women that's
right that also now taking a back seat
and what are we gonna see in the future
so it's a it's a tough situation all
around of course outside in general in
life but we're bemoaning our profession
a more directly and then we had the
world champions you in june visiting us
here for the carrots cup it was also
very promising and then just to shut it
down like completely shut down I mean
it's necessary of course I mean
decisions make that are being taken
lightly mm-hmm
we do have to think what is gonna happen
to our sport moving forward now the way
I'm looking at it and we'll go back to a
question from one of our callers I mean
I do imagine that we're going to be
playing tournaments online not
necessarily the candidates yes but I do
imagine I'm not saying a US Open but we
had isolated Queens the other day which
I thought was a very cute I think it's
time for chess streaming I hope it
becomes more more popular we have great
channels such as bras on your part oh
sure are we happy caro nakamura-san a
chat stream on twitter we have of course
alexandra both is a very popular
streamer yes it's a it seems like a
golden age of course an internet with
streamers yeah but for chess itself I
mean I understand the chest lends itself
to being an Internet sport but it's not
it really is a physical sport that there
is so much tension that you get over the
board all the psychology that goes into
the game it's it's an over the board
game that that will not be replaced
they're two different things and we
determines are just not going to happen
for a while right and we see that by the
way Magnus when I think about really
really active players and I always love
it when we have a world champion so very
active in Magnus has been right there
taking all challengers if you will all
comers and not to see him in action I
mean
look forward every year to the Norway
event yeah you know by the way please in
an alternate universe we would have been
calling this game I know
Kyra wanna versus vos Sheila graph I
mean what a delicious matchup that would
have been we would have been in the
throes of battle right now willows Oh
draw or win for which side Fabi was a
point behind he had to make a move now
we'd be going all out at Maxime well
that's going to be postponed into the
future all those things are supposed to
still happen as you see there their
matchup the matchup of two of the
greatest players in the world today and
we would have been able to watch this
but guess what we will be able to watch
it some future date we hope we expect
that's a time we expect that to happen
as the second half of the tournament is
set to conclude time unknown but there's
some amazing matchups with a lot of
drama and man talk about one of the most
anticipated second half into a candidate
right I mean because you will have the
building you have everyone tuning in to
see the finish to that one if you are an
interested boy you will be interested
when they reconvene to conclude that
tornament obvious points and why he did
in one determined postponed from the
get-go not now but from you know weeks
leading up to the event was that he
didn't want to serve in hanging over the
players for an indefinite amount of time
zactly
that he thought it was a lot of
unnecessary pressure that the sermon had
to happen when it was scheduled and of
course if it had to be postponed well
there's that's a force majeure but
before I finish this thought we do have
with us former world champion Garry
Kasparov to chime in on what is the
breaking news of the day the Fida
candidates being postponed Gary welcome
to the show thank you very much your
thoughts Gary you called it breaking
news
we have been expecting it so I I thought
it was total craziness to have this
tournament to begin and what's happened
now proves again that fee they just you
know just is not an organization for
national federations worldwide but it
just listening to signals from Kremlin
the moment Putin showed up and told
about the crisis the total was over
so but I I don't know how they can get
out of this situation because there is
no solution both from common sense or
from legal point so what are you gonna
do with Raja you know okay bring him
back what about MDL he's now just he's
on the top of the tournament and now
they spent two weeks in the Karen tale
in Moscow
so I've no doubt that it affected badly
his performance yeah and let's see how
are you going to force him to start from
the same position look it's a question
of the question of the question but it
shows total incompetence and politically
motivated actions by the leadership so I
don't know I don't see any any any
solution so it's just since they you
know they just proof so that they aren't
capable of organizing you know events
and you know I'm the World Championship
match world championship cycle under
these circumstances
so I'm but I'm my sympathies over the
players because I can imagine it now
just for them you know showing up on
stage you know just making moves and
just you know thinking oh my god you
know so is it my last game I trying to
speaking I am puzzled how how they can
get out of the situation and what's
what's what's next what's next for the
world of chess and we should talk about
the future of the world of chess okay
should move you know line
but it is a different game right uses
that unlike soccer or basketball or
other games we just can't be played
online you can't beat air you have a
question would you then comfortable with
the candidates being online no I don't
we hopefully will not reach this point
but right now it's not you know it's
while again I don't think I don't want
to ruled out yeah I think it's it's it's
it's possible but right now you know you
have to decide how you can get out of
the situation where you had this seven
games play you cannot you know wipe them
out
but at the same time I don't know
whether you can force dink or karana to
accept the results of the first round of
the front of the first round
it's skin of course he can do it he can
force them and he's already announced
that the results would stand I don't
understand it that's the--that's reminds
me of 1985 you know this come from Alice
said okay the match is over we'll start
a new one okay you decided to start from
the scratch the suit that you know
giving Karpov 2-0 advantage would be too
much but we are now facing the same
crisis and this crisis can be easily
avoided 10 days a girl they could either
make a decision not to run the
tournament and then would not be
debating debating this and the players
would not be would not be in such
horrible situation where I'm sure they
feel the being used and now they're just
you know the thrown out and then they
would be told to come back to work in
three four five six months by the way we
don't know when because fee to cancel
they're a little bit just Halliburton
Moscow in August in long haul and we
know that bigger impact in Tokyo has
been postponed your euro Soccer Cup was
postponed so so many things have been
postponed indefinitely and and we just
we were in the midst of the of the of
this crisis in the world of chess and I
frankly speaking I have no I have no
idea how they're going to resolve it let
me just clarify what I think your
thoughts were regarding this event
Gary the the way I think I understand
what your meaning is they played this
first half but they've played this first
half under this incredible duress
what Grisha called a hostile environment
with people with maths and testing and
that's one half of a tournament that's
quite unfair and then the second half
presumably it's a very normal event that
the kovat virus has passed and it's a
it's it's there's two tournaments and
they're very that's that's the key you
said two tournaments but it's not two
toilets into a one torment right now
what are we having this way I won't want
me to end it and I don't understand how
they can force players to accept the
result okay and they all will be happy
but you know a javo will challenge MVL
every else right to play the first spot
it's the it's a legal question exactly
yeah so the whole idea that you can
separate the tournament
and then just to start you know afresh
from the second round I don't think even
fly mm-hmm it's just it's I think I
don't know how they going to solve the
collision between m and the L and our
job oh it's that's again that's that's
for them to decide but I don't believe
they have any more rights to start from
the from the from the second second
round just you know it stopped it's
still in the rules so they were told
that if the tournament was to be
suspended the players did agree in the
players meeting that they would continue
with the results that would be standing
until then so as far as how they would
convince them that is what they agree to
verbally there's nothing that I far as I
know yeah that is in writing so of
course that could be challenged but as
far as I'm concerned the players agreed
on this right that's the again this is
this yeah when you when you have a gun
at your head you know so you agree on
anything so that's the that's again
that's a problem that I defeated you
know we don't practice this this this
type of behavior
authoritarian behavior for for a very
long time and I think players saw no
choice but accepting it oh I've no dog
in this fight so if they accepted it
fine but I believe there would be a lot
of questions asked and again you have
her job of you know with a legitimate
claim that you know he warned about it
and by the way many other players top
players like Kramnik said that he warned
she warned them three times he demanded
you know this and I didn't listen
which is again amazing you know there's
so many people told them it would not
you know end up nicely
it just it's it's it's you have this
crisis and they they ignored it you know
just two days ago her courage was
insisting that it would go on Kara show
must go on yeah that's the and again the
moment putin said it's over it was that
said fidei does have it in their
regulations as the governing body of
chess that they have the right to
replace a player like right raja baath
for stated reasons and you can read it
in in their in their regulations that
dictate that they could replace a player
who decides not to participate if they
feel that the grounds are necessary so
it seems like they do have their own
documentation that says this is the
conditions that you're playing under but
again but the tournament was not over
exactly exactly for the reasons Rajah
before a job of sighted as as as as the
ground for his refusal he asked them to
postpone the to make it they did it
eventually okay look I don't know what
will be the outcome I think that's it's
unlikely to see players revolt but it's
it's for the world just to decide
whether these kind of people can run can
run this agenda because they they prove
to be totally incompetent and and
ignoring the interest of the players and
the interest of the of the chess fans
because again it stays nobody great
dissatisfaction among managers fans you
know from China to the United States
about about the way the event has been
wrong Gary I don't know if you picked up
on this the
there was two Chinese ladies who Yvonne
and hang yeah who did a commentary and I
had a million people watching online
from China
do you see China as a future of chess
look I what is the future of chess if
it's if it's online you know we can go
to any corner of the world naturally
China with with number of people who
live there and play chess you know it's
it's it's potentially very big market
for the game of chess but so so India
it's just about the same number of
people and and I don't know which kinda
has more grandmaster these days
definitely definitely China has has more
top players because since this vision
and India failed to come up with the
player of that of that caliber but look
it's it's you know if I'm just watching
it from China you know it would be great
disappointment because we you know
Chinese they had big hope big hopes for
dink and I've no doubt that his
performance I mean just he played very
poorly was heavily influenced by too
it's counted in the Moscow countryside
right it's it's I mean the way he played
you know just this the first half was
yeah
unrecognizable let me ask you something
I'm curious about whether or not this
events had been postponed or or picked
up the way it is right now sometime
later the person who comes out of this
event though as the winner will have a
truncated amount of time to prepare from
Magnus right no matter what the
situation was you as someone who have
been in all the wars as a world champion
and you were a first-time candidate
yourself when you played Karpov what is
gonna be the challenge for that person
is it gonna be enough time in your
opinion or what is enough time to get
ready because they're not gonna be able
to focus on Magnus until very late stage
as opposed to having what would have
been a full nine months they're gonna be
down to possibly for two or three months
it's okay
you you assume that you know the state
the second half of candidates or
whatever it is will take place in July
August or September September is but I
don't understand how you can you can
have the World Championship match in
December again it's probably you know
following regulations they can or
whatever they're warm they can start
match next week I'm not sure Magnus will
be happy about this as well so this is
but again that's it's it's about us to
make she's saying that's enough was
enough you know if you know the whole
world you know is moving events why the
World Championship match is not moving
if you if you have the candidates in
September you have to move all channels
should match the 2021
so the Bingle embed you know in Tokyo
moved Olympics tens of billions of
dollars that stayed they moved it Euro
Soccer Cup the championship European
football championship move so you're
talking about the events that involve
billions and billions of dollars in
advertising and watch like let's let's
let's agree by numbers you know numbers
that are far far superior to any any any
any any chess fans in the world and
there is no choice so and now you're
feeling that they stubbornly say no will
plagued you know because it's in
calendar so they already screwed up once
now I think it should be a pressure on
them to move every single they cancel
their limited in Moscow so why this why
they are not announcing about the about
the not the change of the calendar but
saying that will have the event
hopefully in in late summer or September
but we will not we will not stick to the
to the date of the World Championship
match because it's unfair for for for
candidate for for winner of the
candidates and also I think again it's
the now sticking who is any date
original date who you know could cause
more problems for the rest of the
calendar all right Gary turning to
another question yourself you're
probably like everybody else you're in
New York itself isolating you take
advantage of the situation
turn it around will you do some
streaming I will yes I'm just planning
so that's you know just to have this new
equipment and we'll be doing some
recordings from my apartment guess
that's that's a way to communicate with
with all audience you know the yes let's
look at the positive side if you can see
from the window I'm just having a little
you know tour you know about 30 minutes
last night with our family so just
around the block so it's I don't know
what said Louise but in New York
you see empty streets it's a girl city
Broadway you know you can cross brother
in the red light it's like some
dystopian movie without the zombies and
the damage just all everybody it's a new
challenge and the skin just it's we we
have to apply common sense and it's this
you know it's not about you there you
don't have to be an expert in in in in
virus viruses or epidemiology it's about
math statistically if everybody stays at
home for two weeks the virus dies so
that's again it just it's about numbers
unfortunately it's the we had so many
contradicting messages here in the
United States and I think many European
countries didn't take it seriously parts
of cross point but even now again just
we hear this noises from the White House
about you know restoring economy I mean
that's that's it's crazy in the middle
of this of this crisis so unless the
unless you know the this pandemic is
contained so so far we see very little
evidence is happening tomorrow or next
week and while New York is now is at the
center but I mean look but New York has
resources and more worried about other
places in the country like look at
Louisiana now you have this the governor
of Mississippi I mean just talking about
you know just
he's bragging about Mississippi being
what mu okay this is some people should
be tested in their for their brain
capacity it's just it's just that's
where the real problem can happen
because New York can mobilize resources
or California but other states you know
they they made in this trouble seriously
because their health healthcare
infrastructure is not not not only good
shape at all well we definitely want you
to stay safe Gary absolutely we are
forgiven but you are you and me we are
[Music]
New York is my home as well so there's a
challenge of getting back into New York
but let me just just say if you're
streaming online please let me know so I
avoid the time your streaming traffic
thank you very much for joining us Gary
bye bye for now
Wow sharp remarks but certainly
instructed from Gary yes very critical
fides decision to continue with the
tournament to continue with their plans
that they seem to be making and I think
a lot of the problems that do arise is
that I'm part of the criticism is that
even if it was a very low percentage
chance as this tournament would be
postponed eventually it was how do you
fix it going forward right because once
the tournament's postponed Gary's right
it's not one tournament it's two
different things two different
mentalities and it's just not the same
mm-hmm it's ironic that you had
mentioned that Fabiano liked the idea of
pushing the tournament and making it
happen so you could get it over it over
with you know it's not on this
professional schedule anymore and the
irony is that no it is if the worst of
both were
old you know like the tournament started
and it's an abeyance it's just kind of
hovering and it's right it's very very
unclear when it will be scheduled well a
lot of questions to be asked so many
tournaments that have to be rescheduled
the US Championships that we're coming
up in April SEC we have now the
candidates needs to be rescheduled a lot
of things to think about the Olympia
have been pushed out that we've got a
grand chest or all of those events that
we have to think about a reschedule may
be 21 21 as Gary sang is get it all gets
compressed into some time slot of course
if you know we know Gary doesn't love
fidei no that's been for a while oh yeah
but there is this challenge if you say
okay we're gonna take the world
championship mansion we're gonna drop it
in 2021 that if things were going to be
normalized in 2021 so to speak
normalized in 20 you know let's say for
example by September issues are resolved
that's still a far way away far away
we're only in March let's say in six
months
things are health care systems are
together and we figured some things out
you drop the world championship in 2021
all your events that you want to plan
for 2021 have to respect the gravitas of
that event precisely that event takes a
while it's a complete and in the length
of time you're nobody's gonna want to
schedule anything during that event so
so it will dictate everything else on
the calendar Magnus Carlsen
participation in all the events he does
participate in will be affected if he
knows I've got a I've got to work for
that period of time in 2021 so this is a
mess there's no question about it and we
have a fellow New Yorker on the line
Grand Master Robert Hess Robert welcome
to the show we know you are a streamer
and you're a commentator as well
fabulous work my friend tell us your
thoughts right now about what has
happened so far well great to see all of
you Maurice yes Alejandro and we had
team of a job of
for an interview for like 45 minutes on
the chest like on broadcast and I have
many opinions on this I think that fidei
expressed that they were being flexible
and responsible there were two words
that Arkady dvorkovich and Emil sitarski
used during the show today during
interviews and I think that that's not
the case I don't think it was
responsible I think that it was just the
wrong thing to do
it would be my short take of it and tell
us why oh well so many reasons you know
you're looking across the globe at a
pandemic there are it's not just is this
one player does this one person have the
coronavirus so they tested positive for
codes
Kogut 19 the example i used on error was
it's like riding a bicycle without a
helmet just because you don't get
injured doesn't mean that it's the right
thing to do so just because somebody
doesn't end up with coronavirus doesn't
mean that this justifies decision to
have determined when March Madness the
NBA season and all big sporting events
around the world were canceled and you
know it's a little bit different timing
wise with the job of in switching with
MBL and still having the tournament but
these are very important discussions
nonetheless well you have there for a
while so I assume the question did come
up what are his thoughts of the
candidates moving forward does he want
to join if he could it seems to be the
case that he does and he in fact used
the word lawyers and lawsuit himself
unprompted so I think he is looking in
to that possibility because well he
didn't play because Cova 19 and the
tournament is postponed because of Cova
19 so it seems like he was kind of right
in that regard Magnus Carlsen chiming in
that he shouldn't play do you think that
this is a controversy that will be
easily settled adding a 9th player to an
event that's already started well I like
that Timur said that they should have
nine players so he was inclusive of
maxime beaugeois grab some people think
they should we start determine without
max team but Tim Moritz seem to think
that Maxime has earned his spot in the
field so props to my java for saying
that much and I don't know I mean the
world champion has a lot of weight in
the chess world
frankly Magnus is a lot of power so I
don't know exactly what will happen I
don't think that fee day was just you
know bow to him and do what he says but
I think Roger has a legitimate claim he
earned his spot in the tournament
Vijay didn't take the protocols that I
deem appropriate in advance of the event
so I think that if they have even
continued Rajah has a rightful place
among the competitors now I do want to
make a little detail that he didn't cost
him did not mention that it would be
ridiculous for him to play this
candidates you've mentioned wild card
for the next one
he 2020 to 2020 the dimension that he
didn't feel it would be justified but
that he would understand it so it he
wouldn't put it out of the question as
far as getting Raj above in this version
of the candidates but definitely not in
the next one Robert what to say
extraordinary times extraordinary moment
how did you learn this morning that
there was gonna be no no round today I
think I heard like many people except
for you yes I know you're not on social
media yeah sir came in talked Alejandra
hey are we ready for round eight what's
the deal here yeah so you didn't get the
memo but it was just really Peter
Dockers Pro report very early with the
breaking news and it was on social media
so I caught wind of it quite early and
then of course I wasn't able to sleep
and you know my whole sleep schedules
ruined because of it but it's important
topic and we had Vladimir Kramnik on the
show as well talking about why he didn't
commentate in the event and that was
interesting from his perspective oh
please do what I have to say why he
didn't why he was not commentating well
he released a statement expressing his
beliefs and pretty much stating that the
tournament should not be happening and
with that being the case he doesn't feel
right to commentate on it as you know
he's going to be focused in the term now
he's focused on his family and just
people around the world I mean he's
clearly empathetic and so that was his
choice and I said to him but I commented
the
for chess calm because I thought it was
also important to have the platform to
discuss this issue in and of itself was
whether the tournament should be
happening and to also recommend people
you know the sanitized to social
distance to take the safety measures
recommended by scientists and medical
professionals so you know there also was
some enjoyment in a time that was very
tough oh absolutely I mean we all we all
came to view the tournament as a respite
from our self isolation and I was
literally looking forward to it so
selfishly speaking I'm disappointed and
now the players are scrambling to get
home yeah that's another thing right the
world senior team championship was
cancelled after our son nhut Kansas
ended after seven rounds because well
there's gonna be problems getting back
to the US among other countries and I
know every country has different
protocols and the Czech Republic was
going in full lockdown at that point but
it's very clear that feeding made a
decision in that case and it should be a
case-by-case basis to some degree but
you just look around the globe and there
are no other events going on and if
that's not a strong indicator of what
you should be doing I don't know what it
is exactly jump in maybe some questions
for your fellow New Yorker indeed I'm
curious what was it was New York like
right now for you I assume that your
home in the city as well I am home in
the city it's a ghost town I haven't
been out in many days as soon as I came
home from a conference what was that
like I don't even know how long ago I
haven't left my apartment really except
to for the essentials and to get
groceries and even that was one time
thing so from all indications hospitals
are overloaded the you know it's really
stressful throughout the city and it's a
nerve-wracking time a scary time for the
whole world but in New York City's been
hit really hard right now and I feel for
everyone and yeah Maurice you know it's
it's tough a final question Robert there
was some discussion we had a caller kind
of call in and ask how about moving the
candidates online what's your thought
about online tournaments yes and you
know obviously the candidates
it's such an important event online
that's a good question because in fact
Timor was asked that same question and
he was like you know he would entertain
that idea like that's an interesting one
and I think that if the event will take
place for a long time why not have the
tournament online there are you know
going to be safety requirements in terms
of anti cheating and everything I have
to put in place but I do think it's
feasible unlike a sport like basketball
or football where you need the physical
presence of the players and you can't
play online chess is something you can
do and you get the same players maybe
it's a bit different right it's a
different atmosphere you're not seeing
tells from your opponent but it is very
legitimate chest nonetheless I do think
it's possible situation we're having
absolutely agree with you that online
chess is a great thing I do view it
differently like they're different
sports but Robert thank you for joining
us thank you sanitized Wow
no we're studying it never happened
before
candidates stopped in the middle well it
all seems to indicate that we have more
questions than answers fetus as Emile's
Sadowski said they're thinking they're
scrambling to get the players out of
Russia they have a charter flight for a
lot of them going to answer down where
they will be redirected to commercial
flights to their countries including
Fabiano who will be flying through
Detroit we think anisha's already on us
when we believe commercial channel
commercial channel already on his flight
from Moscow oh I crazy situation and
once everybody settled in I think Vita
will take a hard look at how this will
proceed and from what we're hearing it's
not just about how and when will we be
hosting the return of the tournament but
will they actually beat out the lawyers
because some outstanding legal issues
outstanding legal issues
Gary brought it up tamer Rajah who
certainly brought it up himself because
the tournament was until you know for
X&Y reasons it was canceled
for the reason that raja baath said this
should be postponed right
does he have legal grounding well that's
in the contract that's in the Philly
regulations and at the end of the day
that will be up to the lawyers
absolutely Maurice jump in with legal I
mean there are so many lenses to look at
at this event from but elite now we've
got a now we need lawyers in chess of
course of course you're gonna need the
lawyers and the big word you said
there's so many ways to look at it Gary
use the word moral I mean it's like the
moral obligations here should be taken
into account so there's this is a
nightmare as a person who has organized
events and to organize three millionaire
Testaments I cannot imagine being an
organizer of an event like this one I
mean this this after you're all your
momentum is going one way all your plans
went one way you're all set tickets
bought everything in the Zen you yeah
every every every bit of investment that
you've put in and then somebody says
guess what there's a challenge that
you're facing right now the world's
facing you got to put the brakes on it
stop it and I don't you know you got
only eight players we know and you say
no but we can control for eight yeah but
there's people are also associated
around the event but we don't have to
have the fans there we don't have the
journalists there we can we can just put
them in a bubble and then then they know
you can't put them in a bubble that's
not how it's going to work this is a
pandemic is gonna affect things that you
cannot foresee and so sitting there as
organizers trying to figure this out and
then deciding to go against it by the
way the players they said they claim
they talk to the players the other
players and those players were willing
to go ahead with it MV al said if there
was a player revolt you know Gary said
gun to your head but if there was a
player revolt if Fabi
ding Lauren and Andres Chuck said I'm
not playing stop I'm not playing
what fee they say they're you know what
we're gonna replace you with XYZ it
probably would not have happened so the
players agreed that this is the rule
they're gonna play under and they were
willing to do it I'm sure they were
massively confused as well as to exactly
what to do
this was a dream come true the moment
had arrived that they prepared for they
were there there was just about to fly
there everything seemed to be pushing
one way and then he said nope reality
check even when it didn't seem as bad
when it was but you know our pandemics
as we now know pandemics are was
experiencing them literally that a week
two weeks three weeks is like two years
right but how to know right there's so
many things when you look about the
health and a lot of fede officials make
this point health in Yekaterinburg was
their number one concern concern
priority they have the medical doctors
they had tests that are even freely
available in a lot of the world up and
down yes the environment was hostile as
Christian could it but the turn-on was
gonna go on and everybody was seemingly
healthy and I think they did believe
that they could keep this up until the
tournament ended - it's good how style
is a strong word I know who shot me
richer cues were hostile ha English is
not his first language word hostile
sounds like somebody is unfriendly
aggressive attacking you it's not like
whew they try to be welcoming to the
players and concerned about their health
right so he might have meant it felt
vastly uncomfortable certainly you know
you are an edge because you were being
tested all the time I don't have an
abundance and caution of caution so I
think hostile is a bit of a strong word
to be used in a situation like this yeah
and I just want to like what Leonard
Otis yes said that there he was in
Russia the situation is what it is and
he said well you know actually all
things considered he was in a really
good space because of all the testing
all of the care all the medical
facilities all of the heightened
awareness of what was going on and now
he's thinking he's going back to to
Amsterdam where he's not going to be
well taken care of it's also hotbed
right when you think about it you want
to be away from the virus not in the
middle
in Europe is being considered to be the
center of it at the center of Europe of
course exactly in for America's New York
Seattle Frisco so it's just it's just
mess it is a huge mess the safe decision
on fides part the safe one would have
absolutely been to cancel smart you know
smart we can we can say smart you know
clearly given the circumstances safe
would have been let's cancel it folks
let's take up this ship we don't want to
be criticized in any way shape or form
let's get the heck out of here so you
know you look at that you might have you
might later err on the side of caution
basically all the time from now on just
err on the side of caution as your first
bet because you just don't know what's
gonna happen
well very smart I think they took a bit
of a gamble that is always been my view
if this succeeded it would have been the
only major sporting event going on
everybody gets to watch the world goes
on we don't have to postpone this thing
which is already quite difficult to do
it didn't pay off right and I think they
couldn't have foreseen it
yeah it's a big gamble and it could have
paid off it handsomely they said what do
we need to do medically to take care of
the players right two or three weeks ago
I mean we're we're really thinking about
that the world was gonna go into a
lockdown you know a global we're still
thinking well some areas will be shut
down
perhaps some flights from here and there
will will be cancelled but the
inconvenience of a restaurant closing
right you know we didn't think the we're
gonna have to stay home that's the
mandate precisely yes hindsight bias is
a very powerful one and I think I want
to remind the viewers a lot of that that
we right now yes of course you told me
the candidates will continue that's
insane right it's clear now clear now
but hindsight bias is one of the you
know all of us are Monday morning
quarterbacks right every no you could go
to event after event after event and say
oh no that shouldn't happen that way
certainly when a Pete Carroll in the
Super Bowl decided the coach I know
let's pass the ball to the animal to
Marshawn Lynch beast mode we get it past
the one-yard line the Patriots wouldn't
know won the Superbowl Seattle would
have won second in a row I mean but all
the math says yeah it was a good play
yeah screw the math run the ball the
ball so that you know hindsight is a
powerful thing and we cannot pretend
today that we feel the same way we do
three weeks ago no no so if raja baath
was right he was right from the
beginning
not because they canceled the event they
were he was right from the very
beginning in my opinion he's you've got
to say he was just right because if this
event had transpired and if this event
had concluded and everything was okay
and the players had gotten a home you
would still have to argue that he was
right from the beginning and of course
you can't - well you can't then say you
can't then say oh yeah everything worked
out perfectly yeah you know what my job
didn't he should have been worried he
was wrong that's not a way to analyze
these things I don't think you can go
back retroactively Lee was he right in
the first place or not and that is the
question you have to ask well now that
this way of the world working out has
gone that way of course we're all gonna
say of course it was right there's the
proof we don't need to think about it it
looks like he was just a song call right
from the beginning and again I'll just
refer to my own experience I mean a
month two months ago I thought that I
would be coming to st. Louis to call the
candidates in the u.s. championship I
was looking forward to it a couple of
weeks ago as getting on a flight
thinking yeah I want to go I want to
call this event this is like gonna be
fun
this is not gonna be actually thinking
of the same thing you went to tournament
started I thought this was gonna be a
great distraction a great opportunity
yes I wasn't sure myself
should the sort of it started in to
begin with right I mean I had some
doubts but at that point I didn't think
oh this tournament it's ridiculous it's
happening no I'm not even close not even
close to that of course situations are
different around the world I came I was
vacationing Costa Rica was enjoying
Spring Break which have
literally Costa Rica just got its first
coronavirus as I was ready to return
here to st. Louis other first car
Novartis case I came to Missouri we just
had one of our first and that week so
the situation it it's remember when it
occurred it was actually very impactful
it was very impactful that we had a case
here at the st. Louis University right
and things progressed incredibly quickly
exactly things exploded the situation in
America changed completely regarding the
virus we started locking down flights
from Europe and it seemed that one day
was completely different from the other
one day it just seems like something is
gonna hit us and the other day the world
changed just in the same way like Russia
today I mean it was literally yesterday
that the news was reported that Russia
was going to lock down it just a mere
space he imagined no more flight maybe
being a [ __ ] and you think this
attrition is getting back let me buy a
flight three days from now I'm gone from
Moscow I'll go back to my home country
wherever that is right suddenly three
days from now became one game we came
that flights not happening right how can
i scramble the next few hours to get out
or I'm stuck here right and I'll argue
as well what's the decision for a week
from now like what's happening a week
from now what are you projecting to say
a week from now where should I be in the
exactly right you might say well you
know you're telling me Maurice New York
yeah it's Ruffin I'm telling you I got
kids there right so that that's a
decision to make and what is it one week
from now what is what what is Missouri a
week from now what is California
certainly you know parts of the country
that may not be getting hit right now
North Dakota and places where everything
well it's not so bad you tell mice you
haven't been tested yet
you know what do you know it's hard for
any of us to pretend we just are living
in on certain times and the feeling we
have right at this second is going to be
the information we have right at the
second is going to be different from the
information we have in a week and the
feelings we have right now could
dramatically alter in a week as well so
that uncertainty certainly is going to
cause a lot of decisions and maybe
people even second-guess
what we we think makes sense right now
and for me I'm going through that you
know personally it's all over the world
it's all over the world so it's tricky
but we know we should do certain things
focusing those things include self
isolation social distancing great
sanitation do all the things right don't
buy up all the toilet paper that's you
know that's much leaving for people who
in need and also don't overload the
9-1-1 system if you don't need to over
the slightest thing make sure you really
are starting to see symptoms because
that's costing lives as we speak as we
know firefighters and police officers
first responders can't do their job in
the critical life-saving situations if
those calls are simply not getting
through so that's very important to pay
attention to in these times as there's
gonna be collateral damage if we don't
behave the right way wise words
yeah always words indeed oh boy and now
we start to thinking about ourselves as
we go back to normal lives as well no
more tournaments for us and are you
going to be doing some streaming
Alejandra what how are you gonna kill
some time I'm not really sure actually
we while the candidates was happening
there were a couple of things that were
in my agenda
first of all preparing the st. Louis
University trust him for the final four
so for that was supposed to happen in
New York actually the debut after the
candidates finished so I was flying to
New York that tournament God first moved
online and we thought no problem we'll
move it online what a great Avenue will
have a TD tournament director and every
one of the venues one at Webster
University one of ours one at Texas Tech
and one of the University of Texas in
Dallas makes sense and it seemed like no
problems right this is lending itself a
week or so not even a week a few days
ago we got noticed that signal is going
into shutdown we can't actually leave
home except for essential essentials
yeah which means that I can't tell my
players go to the tournament room which
is walking
distance right with the tournament
director that's just not possible even
online chess we will need a tournament
director in the room it is a team event
so everybody needs to be the same room
we could even well not you would have a
legal liability liability was so we
could come in and find you all for
congregating everything else at least in
st. Louis it is a Class A misdemeanor so
that certainly had to be canceled even
exactly online version I was also going
to be preparing for the US Championship
exactly you were a wild card violation
here we're looking forward to playing
and pushing the pieces pushing the
pieces see what I learned from the
candidates and you said at the
tournament but of course that's gonna be
postponed as well so I'm gonna have to
well
sit back tomorrow I think I'm gonna take
today off I'll sit back tomorrow and
think well what am I doing with my life
for the next a few months and we we
don't we don't know questions are a
question mark question mark right
certainly we are very fortunate to live
in these times in terms of chess in
accessibility we know yasser is not
online and okay the chest get that
camera in Hilversum yeah i want to see
you people love you we all love you and
we want to hear from your thoughts on
all things Chesson and other matters as
well you have some of the greatest
stories ever and you've been around
you've seen a lot of things so
definitely yes or get all set up but but
we are living that golden age if this
happened let's say 1990 mmm chess is
just dead you gotta know I know yeah
I'll and just like when that happened
chess is there is no access zero zilch
you're not streaming you're not watching
chains you're not playing online you're
doing nothing there is zero you're not
even playing your friends they can't
come over they'll be zero right now
though with all this the
Genet access and everything which is in
this incredible to be to have this
opportunity and we talk about internet
fairness as well there people in the
world who don't have internet access so
we've owned that and hope the world goes
in a direction a fair internet access
but if you don't have it you don't have
all these events now we can actually sit
here and go yeah you know what maybe
I'll stream maybe that's what I'll do
and I'll be able to watch all all the
events or all the great streamers out
there who'll come online and we're gonna
see some great creativity in that sphere
for sure well turning something into a
positive before we go on break we do
have one call that we do want to take
from Columbia Maryland hello caller
thank you for joining us here a name and
question please hi yes sir happy
birthday belated I'm loving loving your
coverage and I was tuning in today and
not super surprised to see that the rest
of the tournament is being postponed
currently I'm calling in regards to an
idea I had with Roger Bobb which is
since things are schedule wise in flux
why not increase the total players to
nine get in Roger balls first half of
his his first seven games against the
individual other or the other individual
eight players the other individual a
player so eight games and then when they
all reconvened together they could
finish up a second half of a nine player
double round-robin it's just an idea
well thank you for the call thank you
for the proposal this seems to be some
questions about that my own my own
thought is once the competition is
started I don't want to see somebody
just suddenly parachuting and then
joining it even wieszczyk has the same
player yeah but but this seems to
moving towards a legal question Gary
raised it
Robert has who had spoken to Timor
earlier in the day which is very
interesting it's gonna be kind of
compromises because even from a legal
point of view let's say the lawyers say
this tournament has to be restarted it
would be with nine players let's say
that can come in and be like no no I
already started this tournament my
lawyers my lawyers are gonna say I
already played my games already also
dictates that there's gonna be all kinds
of problems that honestly are beyond a
lot of ideas and thoughts are gonna come
down to the fine print exactly what do
we have written down what could happen
there will be some compromise for the
players for sure let's take a very short
break we're gonna have grandmaster
linear Dominguez who was actually
working with team we're a job of course
he was also working with a fabric on
runner for the world championship match
and one of the top 20 players in the
world joining us right on the other side
of it don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
want to thank you all for joining us
today for what is certainly an historic
moment we're privileged at ascension to
have a mission with a capital M and it's
who we are and it's about giving back to
the community it's a win for the
Champions Tour and our players it's a
win for the fans and the spectators be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Lewis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception the slough obtained
second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships higher purpose greater
good st. Louis University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the postpone that
candidates as there will be no round
today there will be no around tomorrow
we hope that there is around this year
we actually react don't exactly know how
the timing will continue the plan for
feeding is that this tournament will
continue with the current standings that
you see right there maxima Sheila grab
I'm young napalm uhd ask the leaders
tied for first but due to the fact that
starting tonight at midnight Russia will
be closing its air borders with the
world
the players are scrambling to get home
and the tournament has been postponed
what a situation Yasir unprecedented
absolutely it it's thrown as completely
off kilter but we have one person who
may help us make a little bit of sense
of what's going on in the world
linear Dominguez yes it's with us he's
not getting a good insight at Rajiv's
campus we are being told he was one of
the seconds for tomorrow job of going
into the candidates that sounds like
more chaos by the way more sense chop
off side this sounds like is gonna be
like whoa what the heck because
everybody is is in that situation right
now and I mean it's really extraordinary
question mark question mark question
mark what we do know for sure is that
this event has been postponed that is
what we know we're gonna grab on to
something we know it's been postponed
we know that feed ate the chest internet
International Chess Federation has
Society that the second half will be
played at a later date with the exact
same score with the exact same players
that is known what is unknown is how
first of all the players well we know
that they're on their way or purportedly
on their way to getting home what we
don't know is when this is all clear
when the smoke is all clear what the
legal battles might be will rare job all
be included
if the legal battles will end up a
certain way what time exactly in date
supposedly the place will be the
Ekaterinburg what but will the World
Championships start at the exact same
time they say fides says yes it will
will it won't it the question marks will
continue for some time and this story
will just continue to unfold in the
coming days and weeks and months one I
recall one specific incident that
happened in at least the World Chess
Championship Vladimir Kramnik was
forfeited the game against against
Veselin Topalov where Vladimir Kramnik
it was called toilet gate Vladimir
Kramnik story that was closed and what
happened was the arbiter signed the
score sheet for Topalov recording the
result now why that was very important
was that officially in the fidei
regulations the game is literally over
when the arbiter yeah recognizes the
result now we just think about the seven
rounds where the arbiter has co-signed
every one of these players score sheets
just like in golf you have an official
record of your result man I just don't
see how Timur lawyers could argue
anything against that because it's such
precedent in chess yeah yeah but we
don't know because we haven't read the
contracts right we the contracts between
feeding of the players are confidential
sure those they're there but the feeder
regulations aren't wide open right very
rules like rule 1.43 yes something very
clear that says that they if a player
decides to not play they can be replaced
and that's their right and that's gonna
be the first clause as they have been
drumming that down and I don't have the
number exactly right but that Clause is
very clear that if a player for whatever
reason decides not to play that they can
replace that player and it's not the
world rights it's not New York's rights
it's fee day as the governing body of
chess that makes those rules and you
could have argued against those rules at
another time before they were actually
in place right but once the rules are
set in stone who was anybody to say they
can't follow their own rules
so I feel like the legal standing is
going to be very difficult for him
there's gonna be general outcry of
course and a lot of people already
saying this is just unfair patently we
want to see something different but
their own rules are sitting there in
stone and I think in a court of law
those rules are what's gonna be the dirt
soon another thing that we don't know is
the extra conversations between raja
baath and fetus but it does seem to be
contradicting ideas he is saying that
they were given an ultimatum which
arkady the president said he didn't like
he didn't like the frogs yeah you know
if all the players got together
basically with the consensus of
discussion by the way that it transpired
was basically raja baath said this must
be postponed or I'm not playing feeder
precedent feeder head wasn't happy with
this and basically whatever got axed
from the tournament right perhaps the
way the BIR Tawil did it was wrong we
don't know we don't know the inner deals
of this and the word wrong or I think
it'd be careful use that this is this is
one of those both can be right both can
be wrong he was saying but in the way
that it was handled exactly yeah and
even then how the subtleties right right
because you we have linguistic
differences we you know personal
differences you might say something to
me and I don't like the way you said
that you've said some stuff to me like
that before our live shot that that
alone to cause eggs and by the way
anything written as you yet as we know
yeah sir doesn't because he's not on
Twitter and he doesn't have a cell phone
but you know you you just type something
to somebody and you see it on the page
on the screen with no tone right no
verbal that's did they talk to you did
they sit and say okay let's let's hash
this out I don't really want to play I
think it's wrong did they go back and
forth or was it all written because if
it's written you get a whole different
vibe
I'm interpreting what I see you're
interpreting what you see and then it's
a hot mess and you get into you know
ex-girlfriend we agreed we're never
going to text each other a serious topic
because I'm hearing stuff from you and
yourself or me it didn't help us to
remain now we catch the tone you never
catch in true intent because you're
hearing yourself when you read anything
so in this case if that's all they ever
did who knows who knows they didn't sit
down face to face and obviously they
didn't sit down face to face and have
this discussion I hear a lot of pain
over there from Jennifer Holly of course
we value her input
chess is supposed to be a symbolic of
foresight which makes Roger chest at a
stable rajab of the champion so far of
the abbreviated and then it's a strong
remark there there should always be the
one who suffers before everyone knows
what's going on
safe travels to all especially Fabi with
a long journey ahead strong words from
strong words but not undeserving raja
baath whatever happened between him and
feed it was the first one to say
publicly this cannot happen right I am
one of the players I'm not happy with
this conditions this event should be
postponed
right and that up happening is determine
was postponed anyway of course under
different circumstances and some things
that could not have been foreseen I
think when some of the decisions were
made others will argue the lining was
there it just had to be read difficult
to say their course especially from the
position that we have right now with so
much hindsight but matter what a
situation we have what we do know is
that is a sad situation it's a mess and
it's a sad situation that's absolutely
clear well one of the things again you
know we as Americans and from very
litigants
and if you think about if any one of
these players had contracted the kovat
virus yes I want to be their attorney
because my client was injured on your
watch and you knew that there was risk
that my client so that being said from
what my understanding is they were
briefed in the players meeting this are
the risks where this is what's gonna
happen if one of you contracts this
virus yeah but as an attorney I got off
fully understand your rights and what
you were doing but we do have guests
with us in Grand Master Lanier Domingues
Paris here joining us Lanier where are
you to begin with and hello I'm not too
far from you guys welcome home course in
cleaning just a ten minute drive from
the st. Louis trust Bob Lanier you were
part of teamers camp he was said so on
Twitter to us what was the feeling when
this negotiations were going on with
fita the tamer might drop out and all
this work for nothing
well actually it was we were I mean I
participate in one of his camps but I
was I was not really with him when when
although all the negotiations with I
mean regarding the virus and all these
things started to happen so yeah when I
left the situation was pretty simple he
was going to play and and everything was
going well and then I was really know
all the things I mean in the news where
he was I mean he was saying it but was
probably right at that point that I mean
it was dangerous and he was calling for
the tournament to be postponed and yeah
that's what I left yeah I'm seeing the
situation looks like he had a point he
definitely had a point we don't exactly
know what happened but he didn't end up
playing the tournament what is your
personal feeling do you think that
tournament should be restarted with him
douchey do you think you
continue on without him it's a decision
where nobody has a clear answer but what
is your personal opinion yeah well I
think to start with I mean it looks like
a bad decision in the first place to
have the tournament under under the
circumstances right because I mean first
of all the argument that the players can
I mean it's difficult for the players to
concentrate in these conditions it's I
think it's a strong argument for for
postponing the tournament so now it's
now it's really a mess now it's a it's a
bad situation I think it's the worst it
can happen I was thinking myself because
I also had some tournaments that and so
I was thinking from my point of view it
would be better if if if the tournament
gets postponed then to start the
tournament and then the tournament will
will somehow be canceled in the middle
of the tournament or something like that
because it's a bit strange then people
have to you know prepare again and some
players have almost no chance and and
for such an important tournament like
the candidates to I mean to to play
under the with I mean with being worried
that I mean because of hold the
situation and so on it's it's a pity so
I think yeah I think it was a mistake at
the beginning and the situation with
Timor I'm not sure because I think it
has to do with the with I mean with what
he was discussing with feeding so many I
think many legal terms or something but
in principle I mean in principle it
looks like he was right so it's a bit
unfair now for him not to not to play
and and it's a huge mess because now MBL
is in the tournament so I I mean it it's
a very difficult situation right no
clear answer for that another question
there have been hints online including
by the world champion that Timor just
didn't want to play the tournament
your thoughts on this no I think he was
I mean he was right it's it's just I
think many players also were were saying
this that it was probably not the right
decision to make the tournament on these
conditions so yeah I I think it was a
very bad decision from front field to
start but just to be very clear linear
team or absolutely wanted to play in the
tournament if there had been no kovat 19
he would have been in Russia I believe
so I mean it is I I mean this you have
to ask him but I I think it was a it was
so his plan to play the tournament and
he started to I mean he started to have
worries when the whole situation with
the with the buyers started to get
serious
maybe organizers were thinking that they
could you know somehow finish the
tournament anyway maybe at that point
situation wasn't so serious or they
thought it was not so serious but I
think - yeah - to go ahead and try to to
make the tournament happen like this was
a big mistake because it also has an
influence on the players and and yeah
and now it's it's a bad situation but I
think he would I mean he would he would
have played in normal conditions for
sure linear I mean I suppose you're in
the same situation is that everybody but
you yourself you're an elite top top
Grandmaster of the world your schedules
been thrown in absolutely disarray what
are your plans for the next week months
coming do you have any plans and by the
way what did you what have you had to
cancel what tournaments have you lost
give us a sense of what you are not
going to play in that you had planned
clearly to play I mean I was I was going
to play the US Championship was my my
next big event and
it's obviously also canceled and I just
found out about the Olympia yesterday
although I more or less I saw it coming
I mean it was logical that they would
cancel a little link it as well I was
planning to play some other tournaments
too like for example the Russian league
usually played in in beginning of many I
guess very low chances that that will
happen so yeah I mean basically I have
no tournaments for the turn for the
moment so I'm not even sure what are my
plans I mean I'm still trying to make
some kind of plans
but yeah trollee
it will be I mean a year where I don't
play so much which it's not so strange
to me
I did it just a couple of years ago so
in a way it doesn't feel so strange but
yeah it's it's unfortunate but yeah
probably I'll do some some online events
and things like that your emotions about
it I mean you must be itching to play
and not able to you've got to be feeling
some kind of feelings oh yeah no for
sure I was I've I felt that I was pretty
well prepared I worked a lot before I
mean after the rapid in blades in
December which was the last event that I
that I play I took some rest and I was
working and I felt quite well before the
US Championship and although the
tournament's coming so in a way it's a
bit disappointed but also I mean if you
if you look the general picture and the
situation a lot of people are suffering
and it's a really sad situation for for
many many people so I mean it's just
being able to be at home with family and
and you know and just doesn't seem like
a big problem in this big picture so I I
just hope that
god-willing things will get better for
for everyone and that we we can all get
through this beautiful words they're
certainly wise words that we absolutely
appreciate it at this time thank you so
very much for joining us and taking time
out of your day I know it's a strange
time take care of yourself your family
and until we meet again thank you so
much thank you guys all right Wow
I mean yeah hard to imagine like I said
I mean 2019 the golden year Wow being
there in you know emerging is not just
the best threat that China ever had but
a threat to the world the threat to
Magnus yeah and Magnus losing the first
playoff in my years or something
ridiculous
hey chess in Zagreb chess in Romania
Manchester Africa right I'll be John
right just simply exploding all over the
planet that carry the Cairns Cup is a
new event the emergence of a female
chess being a being a having its primacy
2019 was golden indeed it was such a
dramatic here such an awesome year for
chess and we just thought more much more
2020 baby it's gonna be great and we had
an Olympia to look forward to thus
candidates of course the world
championship everything right in front
of us
yeah predicting is very hard business
you know it's that life is what happens
when you're busy making plans yeah it's
a nightmare
yeah like it's weird but it's very real
so let's yeah you know I think the
Lanier's words were wise yeah there's no
chess but there's so much more sadness
going on right that let's put chess in
perspective I recognise the rest of the
challenges that the world has and we're
all part of that battle each and every
one of us even you're sitting on your
your sofa in your home you're a part of
that battle as well
we got to come together as a human
family and fight so that most all mostly
all of us will survive we know that
others have died already
and some sad stories out there let's
minimize that number as much as possible
by behaving the right way right and if
you're sitting in your sofa right now no
you're you're doing well yes yes yes I
heard I heard a joke the other day but
it was it was out of a life you know
life message and joke at the same time
he said that our grandparents were
called to fight World War two and we're
called to sit on our sofas that's that's
not a bad deal not a bad deal you're not
going out there getting shot at you know
you're you're at home and you can relax
not not them can't say the same for the
firefighters and the first responders
the nurses and doctors on the front
lines right now that we so appreciate
the work that you are doing and we know
it's quite sad in just in my city of New
York over 200 policemen have been
infected I think it's 40% of the
firefighters have been is what I saw
yesterday have been infected already
because they're going out there and
doing the work that somebody has to do
and so and all the nurses and doctors
who have to literally sit there and
knowing that they might be infected not
enough mass not enough protective gear
and they're potentially taking that home
to their families we are so grateful for
all the work that you do in the bravery
that you're showing and all the rest of
us all that we can do is simply
participate in that and much health to
everybody out there we'll be back as
chess for chess but stay safe everybody
thank you we're going to close our show
with final words of thanks to you all
for sharing and joining us as well I
just want to say Alejandro it was a
great pleasure to work with you oh it's
a great pleasure to work with both of
you yes sir everybody that helps us
we've had a relatively bare-bones team
here but the connection
buddy in the production team that came
out they volunteered to be here and
bring this show to you guys of course
it's a pity that had to be cancelled and
postponed but it is what it is my mind
right now is with the players a lot of
them are friends with of mine and I'm
told that they do have problems leaving
Russia
oh so hopefully I get in touch with
everybody thank you for joining us so
you're gonna go scramble immediately
yeah yeah sure to get online with
everybody and again a big shout out to
our production team who every day has
been waking up extremely or early Gen
who makes us all look good and safe on
the set thank you to the Chess Club the
st. Louis Chess Club for hosting us and
for takeoff
yes but they did they really they really
pull through it I'm doing a little job
exactly so once again I saying
goodbye from st. Louis Chess Club thank
you all for joining us and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]